l'ordre du jour appelle les questions au
Gouvernement la première d'entre elles
va être posée par Madame Michel Tabarro
pour le groupe les républicains
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente la question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
au France voici venu le jour où il te
faut rendre des comptes ces mots remplis
de haine envers notre pays sont issus du
troisième couplet de l'hymne national
algérien le président teboun vient de
généraliser son utilisation par décret
alors que ces paroles n'étaient
prononcées que lors du congrès du
flneux pour le président Macron qui
prétend des vouloir donner un nouvel
élan à la relation entre la France et
l'Algérie
ce n'est pas le premier camouflé le
président algérien était attendu en
France il a préféré se rendre en Russie
pour renforcer son partenariat avec ce
pays qui menace la stabilité du monde
combien d'actes de repentance inutiles
combien de vexations subies avec la
reculade sur les visas et les ingérences
dans nos élections combien de fois
l'exécutif a renoncé pour s'attirer les
grâces d'un pouvoir qui vit sur une
rente mémorielle depuis 60 ans
vous souhaitez normaliser nos relations
avec ce pays mais la France la récolté
que mépris affaiblissement
mépris au travers d'un sentiment anti
français exacerbé affaiblissement
diplomatique à cause de ce choix de nous
tourner vers l'Algérie au détriment de
nos alliés marocains
madame la Première ministre la décision
du président algérien n'a rien
d'innocent
ce n'est pas un acte à contretemps comme
à tenter de le justifier votre ministre
des Affaires étrangères c'est un geste
calculé qui désigne la France comme
l'ennemi et c'est inacceptable oui
madame la Première ministre un hymne
national qui désigne un pays comme un
ennemi c'est inacceptable alors
allez-vous avoir une réaction à la
hauteur de notre indignation allez vous
prendre des mesures fortes telles que
l'abrogation demandée par notre groupe
de l'accord de 1968 qui facilite
l'immigration algérienne en France
allez-vous tout simplement reprendre le
contrôle et donner à notre pays tout le
respect qu'il mérite
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame crazoulazaro
pouloulou secrétaire d'État chargé du
développement de la Francophonie des
partenariats internationaux
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame le député
Michel Tabarro je vous prie d'abord
d'excuser la ministre de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères actuellement à
déplacement la question qui vous posait
est bien entendu sensible très sensible
elle concerne l'hymne d'un pays
étrangère évoque une histoire
douloureuse de fait les couplets en
questionnent a toujours fait partie de
l'hymne algérien composé en 1956 il n'a
donc pas été ajouté
les décrets du 21 mai 2023 formalisent
la pratique selon laquelle l'hymne
algérien est désormais santé dans son
intégralité comment il a occasionne de
les dylaministes de l'Europe et des
Affaires étrangères Madame Catherine
Colonna ses décisions semblent à
contretemps 65 ans après l'indépendance
algérienne notre ambition commune avec
l'Algérie et les Algériens et donc de
regarder notre histoire en face cette
histoire il ne s'agit pas de l'escamoter
ni de nous enfermer nous devons nous
projeter vers l'avenir
nous travaillons avec nos partenaires
algériens pour approfondir les relations
entre nos deux pays dans l'esprit de la
déclaration d'algers pour un partenariat
renouveler entre la France et l'Algérie
c'est un choix exigeant mais les dents
littéraires de la France de le suivre
comme dans celui de l'Algérie je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre
[Applaudissements]
mes chers collègues la parole est à
Monsieur Jean-Victor castor pour le
groupe GDR
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente tout d'abord
permettez-moi au nom du groupe GDR de
saluer l'annonce de l'entreprise au
panthéon du résistant communiste
d'origine arménienne Missak Manoukian
ainsi que de son épouse Mélinée
ma question s'adresse à Monsieur
Christophe Béchu ministre de la
transition écologique et de la cohésion
des territoires monsieur le ministre en
Guyane sur une superficie de 8400 000
hectares vous avez décidé que 95% du
foncier relève de la l'unique propriété
de l'État et que 91% du territoire
soient placé en diverses zones protégées
par amazonien de Guyane parc naturel
régional Conservatoire du littoral
biotope Ramza et maintenant zan en
définitive vous avez décidé que moins de
5% de notre territoire soit aujourd'hui
aménageables or l'urgence
socio-économique est évidente et appelle
des réponses fortes en matière de
production de logements d'équipements
publics de base et de fonciers
économiques aménagés vous savez que
l'INSEE annonce un doublement de la
population guyanaise d'ici 2050 il faut
donc bâtir ce pays Guyane en tenant
compte de son environnement exceptionnel
et de ses réalités la mise sous cloche
au nom d'une vision Paris de la
protection de l'environnement est
totalement irresponsable et laisse place
au chaos déforestation anarchiques
pillage des ressources pollution des
sols et des rivières multiplication des
squats
l'empilement des mesures toujours plus
drastiques se traduit par une insécurité
législative et administrative qui
empêche tout développement de gènes et
constitue le terreau de crise sociale
oui il y a un point d'équilibre à
trouver entre la protection de
l'environnement et le développement mais
il ne peut pas être décrété et imposé
depuis Paris monsieur le ministre pour
aménager son territoire la Guyane attend
la restitution totale du foncier aux
acteurs locaux le désenclavement routier
la fin des blocages administratifs que
répondez-vous au guyanais
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Bérengère Couillard
secrétaire d'État chargé de l'écologie
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
castor la biodiversité en Guyane elle
est extraordinaire plus de 5000 espèces
de plantes 740 espèces d'oiseaux la
biodiversité guyanaise est encore
aujourd'hui préservée la Guyane
française dispose vous avez dit d'un
réseau conséquent d'espace protégés qui
couvre aujourd'hui plus de la moitié de
sa superficie totale elle contribue
ainsi largement au réseau d'air protégés
français le gouvernement est très
attentif à bien concilier protection de
la biodiversité avec les enjeux de
développement qui doit être à la hauteur
des attentes d'aiguillanais c'est
d'ailleurs l'essence même de la
politique r protéger française que de ne
pas mettre sous cloche comme vous l'avez
dit mais au contraire de concilier
finalement les enjeux écologiques et
économiques réduire la protection de la
biodiversité à une contrainte est un
raccourci que je déplore la nature est
aussi une chance elle apporte des
services écosystémiques importants aux
communautés locales par exemple le Parc
amazonien de Guyane en participant
activement à la lutte contre leur
paillage illégal contribue à la
protection de la santé des populations
vous le savez monsieur le député mieux
que personne le taux de mercure
supérieur est à la norme OMS chez plus
de 70% des enfants Amérindiens de
Haut-Maroni lutter contre leur pariage
et la déforestation illégales qui
conduisent à des pollutions majeures
c'est donc aussi se préoccuper de la
santé d'aiguillanais mais vous avez
raison néanmoins il faut s'adapter il y
a des équilibres à trouver nous
regardons si des adaptations des règles
de protection de l'environnement sont
possibles pour tenir compte des
spécificités locales qui sont
importantes ce que permet l'article 73
de la Constitution ainsi dans le cadre
du somme nous proposerons des
simplifications pour faciliter
l'aménagement de la Guyane je peux donc
vous rassurer monsieur le député quant à
notre souci de concilier sans ambiguïté
protection et de l'environnement bien
sûr et le développement de l'activité en
Guyane je vous remercie merci beaucoup
madame la ministre la parole est à
Madame Marie pochon pour le groupe
écologiste merci Madame merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
Madame la Ministre et collectivités
territoriale
la campagne c'est bien pour penser à
rien un clin d'oeil du regretté volanski
manifester manifestement cette citation
vous a plutôt inspiré pour votre plan
France ruralité mais au contraire de
votre vision misérabiliste de ces 88% de
territoires français ces habitants non
aussi résignent pas ne quémandent pas ne
manque pas d'idées mais pour s'adapter
compenser inventer ils et elles doivent
être entendus les habitants des
territoires ruraux ont deux ans
d'espérance de vie en moins que leur
compatriotes urbain 50% des féminicides
ont lieu en ruralité alors que seulement
un tiers de la population Ivy 56% des
mers ruraux ne veulent pas se
représenter en 2026 l'état failli à sa
mission républicaine
la semaine dernière vous annonciez
quelques millions pour une ribambelle de
dispositifs techniques mais cette liste
elle a Prévert nous répond ni aux
besoins de décentralisation ni aux
besoins criants d'investissement quels
engagement pour le retour des services
publics quelle politique d'installation
massive en agriculture quelle mesure
pour les mobilités alternatives au
tout-voiture quelle solution pour la
lutte contre les violences faites aux
femmes en ruralité hier main dans la
main avec le rassemblement national vous
refusiez de réguler l'installation des
médecins demain vous vous opposerez à la
régulation des meublés touristiques ou à
plus de moyens pour la rénovation
thermique des centres bourgs pour
affronter les grands défis de nos
territoires ruraux il nous faut un
leadership vous ne l'exercez pas de la
volonté vous ne l'avez pas des moyens
vous ne les cherchez pas c'est pourtant
dans ces territoires que ce jeu notre
avenir les centaines de milliers
doléances des gilets jaunes que vous
avez archivés contiennent certes des
colères mais aussi tant de réalisation
et d'espoir si un jour vous en prenez le
temps vous y lirez des merveilles
d'innovation démocratiques d'engagement
pour la transition écologique pour
l'égalité des droits pour ces millions
d'actions de solidarité que savent
tisser nos citoyens quand ils doivent
pallier l'absence de l'État madame la
ministre quand allez-vous reconnaître
les impasses sociales et écologiques des
politiques de métropolisation quand
allez-vous enfin changer de paradigme et
reconnaître les campagnes comme actrice
des transitions en mettant un terme à la
course effrénée et suicidaire à la
croissance économique je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma chère collègues la
parole est à Madame Dominique fort
ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
pochon vous avez raison les territoires
ruraux attendent beaucoup de nous et ces
moments qui vous dirait le contraire au
bout de 66 visites dans les territoires
et d'ailleurs je vous y ai rencontré le
15 juin dernier
à Saulgé dans la Vienne la première
ministre annoncée ce plan France
ruralité alors ribambelle de mesure
évidemment ça je ne partage pas c'est
des choses qui sont extrêmement
structurées et qui ont mis tout
simplement la transition écologique au
cœur de nos territoires ruraux alors
c'est le fruit d'un travail que l'on
poursuit depuis maintenant 9 mois il se
construit autour de quatre axes soutenir
davantage nos mères ruraux donc
aujourd'hui village d'avenir c'est un
programme d'ingénierie au service de nos
mers ruraux pour tous les projets qu'ils
voudront porter vous voyez bien là que
le sens c'est que les projets émanent du
territoire et ils viennent chercher
pardon des financements
d'ingénierie pour pouvoir délivrer plus
de services à nos habitants des
ruralités ensuite vous nous interpellez
sur le sujet de la transition écologique
et bien c'est reconnaître et rémunérer
les aménités rurales c'est tout
simplement 90% de nos forêts qui sont en
territoire ruraux c'est 79 millions de
tonnes de CO2 qui sont captés par an et
donc tout simplement la dotation
biodiversité qui 40 millions nous allons
la passer à plus de 100 millions d'euros
en faveur de nos communes en ruralité et
puis c'est apporter des solutions au
quotidien autour de la santé autour des
mobilités et autour de la lutte contre
le logement vacant tout ça pour
améliorer la qualité de vie de nos
concitoyens pour finir c'est la
pérennisation de nos zones de
revitalisation rurale qui ont tous
simplement pour but de faciliter
l'accès à nos médecins à nos commerces
de proximité à nos artisans et à nos
industries dans les territoires ruraux
on voit bien que les quatre axes qui
correspondent aux attentes de nos
habitants en ruralité sont nous y
apportant une réponse avec France
ruralité je vous remercie je vous
remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Thomas rudigos
pour le groupe Renaissance
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Ministre de l'Intérieur ce week-end dans
la vallée de la Maurienne les
soulèvements de la terre ont une
nouvelle fois organisé une manifestation
interdite 12 de nos gendarmes ont été
blessés et je souhaite ici saluer leur
courage et leur professionnalisme face à
des personnes qui cherchaient la
confrontation
[Applaudissements]
la raison de ces violences mes chers
collègues la construction du ligne
ferroviaire entre Lyon et Turin oui les
mêmes qui reprochent au gouvernement une
prétendue inaction climatique s'oppose à
une ligne ferroviaire qui permettra de
basculer plus d'un million de poids
lourds de la route vers le rail ce
projet mes chers collègues permettra
d'améliorer la qualité de l'air des
vallées alpines et de répondre à nos
objectifs climatiques alors qu'elle
comble de la part des parlementaires
écologistes et insoumis de manipuler
ainsi l'opinion contre un projet
essentiel pour les Alpes et ses
habitants ses habitants qui le
soutiennent après de
85%. les ronalpins souffrent de la
pollution et certains inventent une
fable sur l'eau aspirée par le tunnel
l'Europe et l'Italie s'impatient devant
notre retard et certains tergiverse
autour d'une voix du XIXe siècle
complètement inadapté alors je vous le
dis mes chers collègues sortez de vos
postures de vos dogmes et écoutez plutôt
dans votre camp ceux le social Lyon
Turin les socialistes les communistes ou
encore les écologistes suisses qui ont
soutenu la construction de seulement
trois tunnels transalpins 3 tunnels je
tiens à remercier monsieur Clément
Beaude mais ils étaient transports pour
son soutien déterminé et qui vient
d'annoncer le financement des voies
d'accès au tunnel les heures avec les
forces de l'ordre sont devenues une
norme entretenue par des groupuscules et
soulèvements de la terre que la
République mes chers collègues ne peut
tolérer monsieur le ministre de
l'Intérieur
quelle mesure comptez-vous prendre pour
empêcher ce mouvement radical de frapper
encore
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Gérald Darmanin
ministre de l'Intérieur et des Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs députés monsieur le député
rodigoz j'ai également une pensée pour
les 13 militaires de la gendarmerie qui
ont été blessés ce week-end aucune cause
monsieur le député ne justifie que l'on
blesse des policiers ou des gendarmes
je voudrais rappeler que cette
manifestation était interdite confirmée
à deux reprises par la justice de notre
pays que malgré cette manifestation à
interdite 2000 à 3000 personnes dont
malheureusement des élus de la
République
ombraver cette interdiction ne
respectant ni le droit ni la décision
des choses juger et que le travail fait
par les policiers légendaires ont permis
350 contrôle d'armes et d'armes de poing
qui pouvait blesser voir tuer les
policiers et les gendarmes grâce au
travail de nos services de renseignement
et grâce aux autorités italiennes que de
réussir remercier une centaine
d'éléments radicaux venus d'Italie ont
pu être bloqué à la frontière et malgré
cela malheureusement
deux jours d'affrontement une autoroute
occupée une voie ferrée coupée et de
nombreux personnels des services publics
qui sont effectivement devant la haine
et la violence alors oui à la demande du
Président de la République et de la
première ministre demain matin je
présenterai au Conseil des ministres le
décret de dissolution les soulevant de
la terre
je vous remercie monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jérôme buisson
pour le rassemblement national
ma question s'adresse au ministre de
l'équation nationale monsieur papendi
madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues le 16 mai
dernier à Nice un groupe de 10 élèves
s'est réuni sous le préau de leur école
pour prier des faits intolérables qui se
sont répétés dans trois autres écoles
plus de 1000 signalements à la laïcité
dans nos établissements ont été
enregistrés lors du mois d'avril et de
mai c'est presque le double que la
totalité du premier trimestre de l'année
dernière il est clair que notre école
fait face à une nouvelle offensive de
l'islam radical une offensive contre
laquelle vous restez passif comme Lionel
Jospin lors de l'affaire des foulards de
Creil vous vous défaussez sur les chefs
d'établissement et les laisser apprécier
ou non le caractère religieux de la Baya
ou du Cami imaginez un chef
d'établissement affronté seul sans
soutien de sa hiérarchie la volonté
d'une cinquantaine ou d'une centaine
d'adolescents galvanisés ne vous
souvenez-vous pas des intimidations qui
a subi le chef d'établissement du
collège de Creil quand il a décidé
d'interdire le port du voile trois
jeunes filles concernées même après
l'ignoble assassinat de Samuel Paty vous
jugez bon de laisser le personnel de
l'éducation nationale en première ligne
face aux provocations fondamentalistes
vous recréez par votre inaction les
conditions qui ont mené au meurtre de
Samuel Paty oui il faut être courageux
aujourd'hui pour être prof au collège et
au lycée et expliquer qu'une abeille à
une tenue confessionnelle surtout quand
on vous filme en train de demander à
l'élève de l'enlever monsieur le
ministre vous demandez au chef
d'établissement et aux professeur de
faire preuve du courage que vous n'avez
pas pourtant des solutions existent mon
collègue Roger judo avait proposé de
rendre obligatoire le port de l'uniforme
à l'école mais vous avez rejeté cette
idée je vous propose avec ma proposition
de loi de définir par décret une liste
des signes et tenue toujours considérés
comme manifestement appartenant à une
appartenance religieuse vous ne pouvez
plus laisser les chefs d'établissement
seul face à l'islam politique
monsieur le ministre quand allez-vous
enfin le rapporter un cadre clair
d'applications à la loi de 2004 et le
soutien dont ils ont cruellement besoin
la parole est à Monsieur pas Penda
ministre de l'éducation nationale et de
la jeunesse
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
buisson le cadre juridique et clair
c'est celui de la loi de 2004 qui a une
porte et générale et qui interdit donc
toute tenue ou tout signe de nature
religieuse ou à dimension religieuse
dans les écoles et les établissements
scolaires cette loi doit être absolument
respectée il en va de même naturellement
pour des manifestations religieuses
comme celles que vous venez d'évoquer
qui ne relève même pas de la loi de 2004
mais d'une décision antérieure du
Conseil d'État de 1989 il est clair que
toute manifestation prosélyte est à
proscrire absolument et le maire de Nice
comme moi-même sommes tombés d'accord
pour à la fois condamner ce qui s'est
passé et former évidemment les agents de
l'éducation nationale ainsi que ceux du
périscolaire pour que de tels événements
ne se reproduisent pas à partir bien
entendu de
du côté des abayas notre position est
également claire elle a été précisée par
une circulaire du mois de novembre
dernier toute tenue manifestants une
intention religieuse et proscrite dans
les écoles et les enceintes scolaires
cela est clair cela doit être respecté
d'un point de vue juridique cependant la
notion d'abaya puisque vous y faites
allusion n'a pas de définition juridique
je nous serions dans l'incapacité auprès
du juge de définir juridiquement ce
qu'est une abaya par conséquent la seule
voie possible c'est celle non seulement
de la fermeté sur les principes le
soutien aux équipes pédagogiques et au
chef d'établissement ainsi bien entendu
que l'aide des équipes valeurs de la
République qui se déplacent dans les
lycées concernés ma position est claire
fermeté
sur les principes aide aux équipes et
puis formation nous avons formé 300 000
merci beaucoup 300 000 professeurs à ce
jour merci monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Madame Anne-Laure Babeau
pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Olivier Klein ministre
délégué chargé de la ville et du
Logement bien sûr et heureusement ce
vendredi soir il n'y a pas eu de mort
mais le traumatisme est profond si la
terre a fortement tremblé en
Charente-Maritime résonant jusque dans
les Deux Sèvres disons le simplement ce
sont des vies qui ont vacillé
environ 250 maisons inhabitables 500
personnes directement impactées sur
place le lendemain j'ai rencontré des
habitants choqués et inquiets en proie
au doute et aux questions ou quand
comment où seront-ils relogés quand
seront-ils indemnisés et à quelle
hauteur comment seront-ils accompagnés
madame la Première ministre monsieur le
ministre il est essentiel que nous
prenions tous la mesure de cette
catastrophe afin d'agir au plus vite
Gérald Darmanin annoncé une procédure
accélérée de recruter sens de
catastrophes naturelles monsieur le
ministre Klein vous êtes rendu hier avec
Christophe Béchu sur les communes les
plus sinistrées au nom des habitants et
des parlementaires concernés je vous
remercie
saluez nos pompiers et nos gendarmes qui
sont une nouvelle fois exemplaires
souligner l'élan de solidarité qui s'est
immédiatement mis en place et remercier
aussi les maires les élus et les agents
communaux qui font un travail
exceptionnel pour recenser les sinistres
et répondre autant que possible à la
détresse des habitants ils ont besoin de
la solidarité nationale
aujourd'hui et demain car nous rentrons
dans une période de temps long désormais
les maisons doivent être sécurisées les
personnes sinistrées doivent être
relogées à long terme dans des logements
décents sur un territoire déjà en
tension immobilière pouvez-vous s'il
vous plaît nous détailler les actions
que l'État va mettre en place et
notamment le dispositif de fond d'aide
au relogement d'urgence je vous remercie
merci beaucoup ma chère collègues la
parole est à Olivier Klein ministre
délégué chargé de la ville et du
logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la député à
de Laure Babeau je veux vous remercier
de votre question et à travers vous
saluer l'ensemble des parlementaires de
Charente-Maritime et des Deux-Sèvres que
nous avons rencontrées hier
effectivement avec Christophe Béchu lors
de notre déplacement chouette d'abord
redire au nom de l'ensemble du
gouvernement toute notre solarité
solidarité auprès des victimes
sinistrées par ce séisme aussi violent
que inattendu nous sommes allés sur
place hier pour saluer l'ensemble des
équipes de secours le 10 la gendarmerie
qui est toujours présente sur place bien
évidemment pour continuer à évaluer les
dégâts et sécuriser les les habitations
qui ont été laissées vides et pour les
protéger et répondre à l'inquiétude
légitime des populations qui ont dû
laisser leur logement et les gendarmes
sont extrêmement mobilisés pour éviter
tout acte de vandalisme ou de ou deux
cambriolages pour ce qui est des
engagements et des mesures qui seront
prises comme vous l'avez rappelé le
ministre de l'Intérieur
a annoncé la mise en œuvre rapide de
l'état de catastrophe naturelle et les
premières cas seront examinées dès la
Commission du 29 juin en attendant il y
a un certain nombre de mesures qui
existent déjà et que nous allons mettre
en œuvre sous le suivi des deux
préfectures notamment la mise en place
de la dotation de solidarité en faveur
de l'équipement des collectivités
touchés par un événement climatique et
je grave le décès qui va être mise en
oeuvre très rapidement et un certain
nombre de subventions pourront être
donnés aux collectivités locales pour
accompagner cette situation en
particulier les collectivités locales
avec des trésors RILs les plus fragiles
ensuite comme ça a été dit à la demande
de la première ministre nous allons
mettre en place le fond d'aide urgence
au logement le Faru qu'il a aussi pourra
venir en complément bien évidemment des
assurances parce que
cet état de catastrophe doit être prise
en compte de manière importante par le
milieu assurantiel nous allons
rencontrer les ass c'est la Fédération
française des assurances pour prendre en
compte cette situation dramatique et
travailler avec vous et avec l'ensemble
des préfectures sur ce cas-ci grave et
si particulier merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Jean-François
Coulomme pour le groupe la France
insoumise merci madame la Présidente
Monsieur le Ministre de l'Intérieur
creusé près de 300 km de tunnel sous 5
massif alpins entre Lyon et Turin exhumé
des millions de mètres cubes de roche de
toute nature siphonner chaque année plus
d'un million de mètres cubes d'eau
potable que recèlent phréatique profonde
ravagé 1200 hectares de précieuses de
terres agricoles défiguré à jamais les
fragiles paysages et écosystèmes de la
Maurienne et au-delà il retrachait des
milliers de mètres cubes de béton
démantelés privatisés les ouvrages
ferroviaires existants afin de les
neutraliser et pour masquer
l'alternative vertueuse qu'il constitue
face à ce titanesque ravage infligé
pendant des décennies encore de
déferlement de poids lourds par la route
et le tunnel existant contre la promesse
d'une infrastructure espérée pour un
horizon 2048
détourné 30 milliards d'euros coût total
des travaux de projets vertueux qui
lutteraient réellement contre le
réchauffement climatique et la pollution
enfin verdir un coup de mensonge une
ruineuse ineptie industrielle qui
revêtira au cours du temps la couleur
d'un saccage environnemental
irréversible et de sa corruption
généralisée voilà l'horizon détestable
et anachronique auquel l'écologie
macroniste condamne les générations
futures avec ce lieu en Turin 2
alors ou des hypocrites célèbrent la
pantéonisation des époux manukian leurs
héritiers se soulevaient d'hier en
Maurienne pour résister à leur tour
contre cette confiscation des biens
communs et leurs saccage programmé
près de 5000 opposants au projet
français comme italien rassemblé dans
une manifestation organisée par les
soulèvements de la terre ont fait la
démonstration du côté où se trouve la
responsabilité et la justice écologique
de notre temps et ceci dans le respect
scrupuleux des articles de notre charte
de l'environnement
fidèle à votre conception autoritaire
d'une démocratie à la française qui
s'impose à notre peuple par la matraque
les mutilations pour exemple et la
criminalisation des comptes spectateurs
votre régime sera-t-il un jour capable
pour la terre et pour nos enfants de se
lever autre chose que la matraque et le
code pénal
merci la parole et à Monsieur Gérald
Darmanin ministre de l'Intérieur et des
Outre-mer
[Applaudissements]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
vous m'interrogez finalement sur
l'opportunité de réaliser le
l'architecture magnifique que sera sans
doute de Lyon Turin mon opinion ne vous
apporte peu mais peut-être que vous
pourriez demander à Monsieur Mélenchon
qui était ministre du gouvernement
Jospin lorsque ce gouvernement a décidé
la construction
de cet ouvrage
monsieur le député
non mais Monsieur Mélenchon a été
ministre de Monsieur Jospin je vous le
rappelle madame Shigeru
allez s'il vous plaît on écoute le
ministre s'il vous plaît monsieur Jospin
est c'est pas une insulte monsieur
Jospin c'est quelqu'un de tout à fait
estimable
[Applaudissements]
monsieur le député j'ai envie de vous
demander si vous trouvez normal que des
parlementaires manifestent lorsque le
préfet interdit de manifestation et que
la justice
confirme cette interdiction monsieur le
député j'ai envie de demander si votre
groupe politique trouve normal que nous
puissions saisir plus de 350 armes
destinées à tuer à la veille de cette
manifestation votre président de groupe
s'est rendu
monsieur le député j'ai envie de vous
demander si vous pensez sérieusement que
l'on peut accepter que des personnes
radicalisées puissent participer à des
manifestations et que vous puissiez ici
soutenir qu'ils étaient de gentils
personnes qui étaient simplement là pour
protéger la nature vous êtes parfois
monsieur le député un peu excessif je
vous cite le 25 mars 2023 la police est
une milice ubérisée et violente quel
pays 22 mars 2023 on la justice est
prostituée par le garde des sceaux
ce sont vos propos
l'instrumentalisation pour niveler pour
élever le niveau de violence autour d'un
trou sans CRS autour les manifestants
les manifestants seront-ils tombés
dedans dictature macroniste
impardonnable merci un dispositif
militaire conçu pour terrifier le risque
monsieur le député soutenez les
policiers pas ce qui les agresse merci
monsieur le ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Bertrand petit
pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la Première ministre
des rembourser les médicaments c'est la
dernière annonce de votre gouvernement
alors que dans le même temps 8 millions
de Français subissent chaque jour des
difficultés dans l'accès aux soins en
raison de la désertification médicale
plus de médecins traitant pas de médecin
près de chez soi pas de rendez-vous
avant plusieurs mois il aurait et ils
auraient le sentiment d'isiez-vous la
semaine dernière en déplacement dans une
petite commune ils auraient le sentiment
que disiez vous que les services
reculent ce n'est pas un sentiment
madame la Première ministre c'est la
réalité dans une démarche transpartisane
mon collègue Guillaume Garraud a proposé
un amendement pour fléchir
l'installation des médecins généralistes
et spécialistes en fonction des besoins
de santé on le fait déjà avec nos
pharmaciens aujourd'hui et vous ne
pouvez le nier alors que des territoires
entiers manquent de médecins là où
l'offre de soins est suffisante il pas
besoin de plus de praticien avec la
complicité des députés du rassemblement
national votre majorité relative a
refusé cette proposition ce serait la
porte ouverte au déconventionnement et à
la crise d'évocations ont entendu sur
vos bancs mais rien éprouvé il faut
inciter dites-vous mais on le fait déjà
et ça ne suffit pas alors que
répondez-vous au 74% de français
favorable selon un récent sondage à
l'encadrement de l'installation des
médecins pour lutter contre les déserts
médicaux qui ont refusé votre majorité
et le rassemblement national
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
santé et de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
petit vous me permettrez le temps est
court de ne pas rejouer le match si je
peux m'exprimer ainsi nous avons eu dans
cette assemblée des débats extrêmement
nourris particulièrement intéressant je
remercie d'ailleurs les groupes qui ont
participé ça a permis de faire des
échanges d'idées très constructifs alors
c'est inégalité territoriale de l'accès
aux soins les déserts médicaux dont vous
parlez c'est une priorité forte du
ministère de la Santé et nous y
travaillons avec la ministre Agnès Firma
le Baudot quotidiennement pour améliorer
la situation de nos concitoyens trois
grands axes de travail si vous permettez
rapidement de les détailler un premier
augmenter le nombre de professionnels de
santé c'est grâce à cette majorité que
nous avons pu faire sauter le numerus
clausus et augmenter aujourd'hui de 15%
le nombre d'étudiants en médecine et
nous continuons dans cette voie c'est
aussi grâce à cette majorité en
travaillant avec les régions que nous
avons pu augmenter le nombre d'étudiants
infirmiers pour les déployer dans les
territoires
deuxième solution c'est favoriser
l'installation et le maintien dans les
territoires les plus démunis sépare la
place du guichet unique pour favoriser
leur installation ce qui a été voté dans
cette hémicycle dans le cadre de la
loire-est également améliorer les
conditions de travail des professionnels
ils souhaitent avoir un exercice plus
RIP professionnel c'est ce que nous
déployons enfin c'est rapprocher les
étudiants de ces territoires c'est tout
l'enjeu de la quatrième année de
médecine générale où les étudiants
feront prioritairement le stage dans les
territoires sous dotés enfin il faut
jouer sur le temps médical redonner du
temps médical c'est ce qui est le plus
efficace le plus rapidement en
travaillant avec l'ensemble des
professionnels de santé c'est ce que
nous faisons par le partage et le
transfert de compétences également en
refondant complètement le métier
d'infirmière pour qu'il correspondent
plus aux besoins actuels donc voyez
monsieur le député ce n'est pas de
l'immobilisme au contraire ce sont des
solutions qui sont éprouvées qui
fonctionnent qui permettent de faire
revenir des professionnels dans les
territoires contrairement à ce que vous
évoquez qui nous le savons tous ne
fonctionne pas et risque d'aggraver la
situation je vous remercie je vous
remercie monsieur le ministre monsieur
petit oui monsieur le ministre parmi vos
solutions il y a aussi celle des
médicaments
de personnes vivant dans un désert
médical très clairement c'est une
rustine devant l'ampleur du problème une
de plus comme vos mesures sur le pouvoir
d'achat les français demandent des
médecins généralistes ancrés dans les
territoires pas des médecins itinérants
et intermittents alors Monsieur le
Ministre les Français sont sûrement pas
tous égaux devant la santé mais ils
doivent l'être dans l'accès aux soins
alors agissez s'il vous plaît c'est
urgent merci beaucoup mon cher collègue
la parole est à Monsieur Benjamin
ceinture pour le groupe yote
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'Économie des
Finances ou celui qui voudra bien se
prêter à l'exercice de me répondre c'est
la fin du quoi qu'il en coûte souvent le
ministre le maire la scander comme étant
une perspective immédiate souhaitée et
absolue il faut maintenant désendetter
la France dès 2023 et malgré un contexte
inflationniste que personne ne peut nier
vous avez fait le choix que vous avez
annoncé lors des Assises des finances
publiques de la fin des boucliers
tarifaires pour le gaz très
prochainement et pour l'électricité en
fin d'année de la fin de la politique
d'échec et de l'annulation d'un certain
nombre de crédits objectifs d'ici à 2027
10 milliards reconnaissons que cette une
toute petite somme toute petite somme au
regard du déficit colossal qui est celui
de la France et pourtant vous aurez du
mal à atteindre ces objectifs en effet
une fois encore vous manquez de méthode
vous n'avez pas su mettre autour de la
table l'ensemble des parties prenantes
qui fonde la dépense publique et qui
sont en capacité de faire un certain
nombre de propositions il pas de vrais
feuilles de route nous sommes finalement
sur pique-nique douille c'est toi
l'andouille on y va à l'aveugle au pif
on essaye de trouver des pistes
d'économie résultat des courses on y va
on choisit la santé en pointant du doigt
les médecins qui font des arrêts de
travail de confort qui vont en sorte de
prescrire trop de médicaments cela aura
un impact directement pour nous
concitoyens qui seront moins bien
remboursés qui paieront plus sur leur
complémentaires vous choisissez de
passer par le logement avec la loi Pinel
vous choisissez de passer par la
formation qui sera moins bien prise en
compte pourtant il s'agit des priorités
des Français au quotidien notamment
autour du pouvoir d'achat vous refusez
dans le même temps par dogmatisme toute
hypothèse de recettes nouvelles autour
des taxations financières autour de la
taxation du grand capital du grand
patrimoine vous le refusez ardemment ma
question est donc simple n'en avez vous
pas marre de faire des cadeaux toujours
au même et de presser toujours ceux qui
au quotidien font la France je vous
remercie
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Gabriel Attal
ministre délégué chargé des comptes
publics
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
sans tuiles
la plus grande politique d'austérité
pour la France ce serait de laisser
filer la dette comme le propose certains
dans cette hémicycle parce qu'elle nous
coûterait tellement cher qu'il faudrait
alors couper brutalement dans la dépense
publique ça n'est pas ce que nous
souhaitons ce que nous souhaitons c'est
garder le contrôle de nos finances
publiques nous avons pour ça établi un
programme de stabilité qui va nous
permettre effectivement de désendetter
la France en revenant sous les 3% de
déficit progressivement et en commençant
à rembourser notre dette nous avons une
stratégie pour ça la première c'est la
croissance et l'activité économique tout
faire pour que l'activité économique
continue de se déployer dans notre pays
et oui ça peut passer monsieur le député
par certaines baisses de fiscalité on
collecte plus d'impôts sur les sociétés
avec un taux à 25% qu'on en collecté
avec un taux à 33% parce que précisément
ça permet à l'activité économique de se
développer deuxième levier effectivement
la sortie des boucliers tarifaire sortie
progressive le gaz d'abord cette année
l'électricité à la fin de l'année 2024
parce que la réalité c'est qu'il faut
dire la vérité aux Français monsieur le
député on ne peut pas garder ses
dispositifs généraux parce que les
finances publiques ne nous le permettent
pas et si nous le faisions ça se
traduirait dans quelques années par des
augmentations d'impôts pour les Français
ce que nous ne souhaitons pas et le
troisième levier c'est celui des
économies effectivement à faire sur la
dépense nous avons avancé hier lors des
Assises des finances publiques un
certain nombre de propositions mais nous
allons y travailler dans les semaines et
les mois qui viennent et notamment avec
le Parlement l'an dernier nous avons
engagé les dialogues de Bercy nous
allons cette année reprendre les
dialogues de Bercy dans une version
augmentée étendue avec mon collègue
François Braun au PLFSS pour échanger
avec la représentation nationale sur la
tenue de nos comptes publics sur nos
perspectives pour les finances publiques
et j'espère monsieur le député que vous
ne participerez à ces travaux nous
sommes ouverts à travailler avec toute
la représentation nationale qui le
souhaitent
la parole est à de jean-car Grelier pour
le comprenais sens merci madame la
Présidente on s'adresse à Monsieur le
Ministre de la Santé de la prévention
monsieur le ministre je suis sur la base
d'un double constat que je souhaite
aujourd'hui vous interpeller le premier
constat tient dans le fait que l'on
produit désormais très peu de
médicaments en France depuis plusieurs
années dépend entier de l'industrie
pharmaceutique ont quitté notre
territoire pour se délocaliser dans des
pays à bas coût de main d'oeuvre et de
production il est probable aussi que les
contraintes tarifaires et autres clauses
de sauvegarde qu'on multipliait les lois
de financement de la sécurité sociale
n'est pas contribué à améliorer cette
situation l'autre constat qui est le
corollaire du premier c'est que de
nombreux médicaments sont régulièrement
en rupture d'approvisionnement laissant
nombre de nos compatriotes dans
l'angoisse d'une rupture de traitement
lors de son dernier déplacement en
Ardèche le président de la République a
fait quelques annonces fortes qui
étaient nécessaires tant pour renouer
des relations de confiance avec
l'industrie du médicament que pour que
pour les patients qui avaient un grand
besoin d'être rassurés ainsi la
production de 50 médicaments jugés
critiques va-t-elle progressivement
revenir en France ainsi encore des
stocks de 450 médicaments d'intérêt
thérapeutiques majeurs vont-ils être
scrutés et suivis de près par vos
services toutes ces mesures qui
s'ajoutent aux obligations de stockage
vont évidemment dans la bonne direction
mais la confiance entre la France et
l'industrie du médicament sera longue à
rebâtir et les mesures annoncées par le
Président de la République si elles sont
un préalable nécessaire ne seront pas
suffisantes
qu'envisagez-vous monsieur le ministre
pour redonner envie aux industriels du
médicament de revenir investir en France
comment seront mises en oeuvre les
engagements du dernier conseil
stratégique des industries de santé
enfin la loi de financement de la
sécurité sociale pour 2024
marquera-t-elle une rupture avec les
précédentes en se traduisant par une
politique tarifaire moins sévère et des
clauses de sauvegarde du transparente je
vous remercie merci beaucoup
la parole est à Monsieur François braune
ministre de la Santé de la prévention
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député-grenier le problème de pénurie de
médicaments n'est malheureusement pas un
problème que français c'est au minimum
un problème européen même au-delà
européen parce que c'est le sujet de
discussion par exemple de la dernière
réunion des ministres de la santé à
l'échelle européenne c'est donc un
problème que nous devons considérer en
France mais également en Europe dans un
objectif comme la demandé le président
de la République de retrouver notre
souveraineté par rapport à la production
et à la distribution de médicaments
alors j'ai eu l'occasion vous l'avez
rappelé de d'annoncer la semaine
dernière une liste de 450 médicaments
essentiels ce sont des médicaments qui
ont été définis par les sociétés
savantes médicales pour maintenir le
traitement de l'ensemble des Français
sur sur le territoire parmi ces
médicaments il y en a qui font partie de
la liste dont vous parliez de
médicaments index thérapeutique majeur
d'autres qui font partie qui n'en font
pas partie mais qui vont intégrer ce
principe de médicaments essentiel
l'enjeu étant de contrôler l'ensemble de
la production de ces médicaments depuis
l'usine jusqu'à la boîte dans la
pharmacie qui est distribuée auprès de
nos concitoyens on a pu voir l'hiver
dernier des incohérences entre ce que
pouvait dire les industriels et est-ce
que les pharmaciens nous remontaient
comme difficulté le président de la
République a annoncé une relocalisation
de 50 de ces médicaments 25 dans un
premier temps qui vont être qui ont été
annoncés dans les choses vont être
précisées dans les semaines qui viennent
l'enjeu est double face aux médicaments
assurer la production de médicaments
matures mais également rend accessible
les médicaments de rupture les plus
innovants pour les Français c'est ce que
nous faisons par exemple avec l'accès
direct en ce qui concerne les calculs de
prix il y a nécessité d'une transparence
totale et c'est ce que nous engageons à
faire avec les industriels la première
ministre annoncé un groupe de travail
sur la redéfinition du prix du
médicament devant les discussions autour
de cette clause de sauvegarde et des
engagements du XIX nous attendons dans
les semaines qui viennent les
conclusions de ce groupe de travail qui
serviront de base à définir les grands
axes de la politique de prix de
médicaments dans les années à venir mais
soyez certains que notre préoccupation
la préoccupation de ce gouvernement
c'est d'assurer les médicaments matures
et les médicaments les plus innovants
pour tous les Français
aymeric Caron pour le groupe LFP
madame la plus
merci madame la présidente madame la
Première ministre mercredi dernier au
large de la Grèce la mer a avalé les
corps et les vies de plusieurs centaines
d'hommes de femmes et d'enfants des
exilés qui tentaient de survivre mieux
ailleurs il s'agit de l'un des naufrages
les plus meurtriers jamais vu en
Méditerranée on estime qu'il y a environ
600 morts parmi lesquels une centaine
d'enfants noyés avec leur mère dans la
cale de leur bateau cercueil en leur
mémoire je vous propose chers collègues
mesdames et messieurs les ministres que
nous observons une minute de silence
je trouve qu'effectivement vous cette
idée est formidable mais la Conférence
des Présidents est là pour ça pour que
nous puissions décider collectivement
des moments dans lesquels dans cette
émission nous honorons les personnes
disparues on ne fait pas 2 minutes de
silence de cette façon là vous devriez
le savoir j'en suis désolé et je suis
navré que vous m'obligez à tenir ce
genre de propos oui c'est désolant parce
que ce sont des moments qui doivent nous
unir et pas nous désunir et des
pratiques telles que celles là nous
déshonore j'en suis navré
vous pouvez dérouler le
monsieur Caron est-ce que vous souhaitez
poursuivre votre question merci
je ne vois pas pourquoi l'improvisation
de ce moment empêcher l'Union
ce silence en guise dommage ne doit pas
nous en faire oublier un autre à savoir
le silence gêné et coupable qui
accompagne depuis presque une semaine ce
drame qui ne doit rien à la fatalité
mais tout à la lâcheté à l'ignomini
l'enquête est en cours mais les
survivants accusent les gardes côtes
grecques d'avoir tenté de repousser leur
navire loin de leur côte et d'avoir
ensuite abandonné les naufragés à la
mort quand la Frontex un avion a vu le
navire en perdition mais il n'est pas
intervenu voilà où nous en sommes nous
laissons délibérément mourir des êtres
humains parce qu'il nous gêne parce que
leur origine leur couleur de peau ou
leur religion ne nous conviennent pas au
lieu de les prendre en charge comme
l'impôt de droit maritime et le plus la
plus aimantée humanité nous les
enterrons en mer depuis 10 ans près de
27000 personnes sont décédées en
Méditerranée l'Europe et la France ne
font rien ou presque ma question est
donc la suivante que mettez-vous en
œuvre concrètement pour éviter que de
telles tragédies ne se reproduisent
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Chris soulaz à
carreaux
secrétaire d'État chargé du
développement de la Francophonie et des
partenariats internationaux
madame le Président Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Americ Caron
c'est une phrase souvenir les 14 juin et
avant tout adram Omar infloyable
je souhaite tout d'abord redire les
profonde tristesse de la France est
renouvelé nos condoléances aux familles
de victimes je vais aussi
rappeler l'entière mobilisation de la
France avec la sable de ses partenaires
européens pour faire en sorte que ce
type de tragédie ne se reproduisent pas
je suis allé à ce titre l'accord
trouvait les 8 juin par les ministres
européennes de l'Intérieur cet accord
vise à porter une réponse européenne
efficace à la question des traitements
de demande d'asile une réponse qui
allait esprit des responsabilités et mis
en oeuvre concrète de la solidarité
entre les États membres ces drames
rappellent aussi l'importance de la
coopération avec les pays pierres en
matière des sauvetages amères et des
luttes contre les réseaux des passeurs
là encore les travaux sont en cours au
niveau européen et en particulier avec
la Tunisie notre objectif est de
renforcer les capacités des états
d'origine et des tranchées nous voulons
ainsi mieux lutter contre ceux qui
exploitent la détresse des migrants et
mieux lutter contre les causes profondes
de l'érection c'est ainsi
mesdames et messieurs les députés qui
nous inviteront de nouvelles tragédie
je vous remercie madame la ministre
la parole est à Madame Émilie bonnivore
pour le groupe les républicain
ma question s'adresse à la première
ministre samedi en Maurienne des
individus violents sont venus caillasser
les forces de l'ordre vandaliser le
garage d'armesan paralysé toute la
circulation ferroviaire et routière en
Savoie effrayer les habitants du secteur
au nom de l'écologie et tout cela avec
le soutien de députés insoumis et écolo
venu faire leur buzz sur le dos des
Savoyards aux côtés des casseurs avec
leur écharpe de députés qui a le honte
député de la circonscription j'ai été
choquée comme des millions de nos
compatriotes je veux dire toute notre
reconnaissance aux forces de l'ordre
gendarme douaniers agents de la PAF
pompier soignant préfet sous préfet
engagés en Maurienne ce week-end dès qui
par leur décision et actions ont évité
le pire face à la désinformation il faut
rappeler que le lion Turin est la seule
infrastructure en tunnel permettant un
fret massif et donc d'améliorer la
qualité de l'air et la vie dans nos
vallées sans sacrifier le transport de
voyageurs ni les habitants vivant aux
abords de la ligne historique et en
toute sécurité les Suisses ont réalisé
la même infrastructure Nord-Sud il
transfert 70% de leur marchandises par
le rail et ils ont toujours de l'eau
chers collègues ils n'ont pas vidé les
Alpes demandez à Monsieur Mélenchon
d'aller faire un tour nous c'est
seulement 8% avec l'Italie par le rail
tout le reste ce sont les populations
les pollutions et la congestion du
trafic que nous subissons dans la cluse
de Chambéry en comble de Savoie en
Maurienne en Haute-Savoie et dans les
Alpes-Maritimes madame la première
minute j'ai deux questions qui va payer
les dégradations locales du garage
d'armesan les soulèvements de la terre
les groupes et les filles écologistes
enfin pouvez-vous réaffirmer la volonté
du gouvernement de faire du lion Turin
une priorité avec une vraie politique de
fret un calendrier clair sur les accès
alors que c'est la seule infrastructure
nationale qui bénéficie de 50% de
financement européens je vous remercie
ma chère collègue la parole est à Madame
Bérengère Couillard secrétaire d'État
l'écologie
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Bolivar vous interrogez sur le projet
LGV Lyon-Turin évidemment je tiens à
remercier également les forces de
l'ordre mobiliser ce week-end en
Maurienne pour empêcher ses débordements
insupportables sur une manifestation qui
je rappelle était interdite par le
préfet de sa voix 12 gendarmes ont été
blessés c'est absolument inacceptable et
l'opposition à un projet
d'infrastructure ne justifie en aucun
cas au recours à la violence ce projet
il est ambitieux les travaux sont
engagés et font l'objet d'un accord
international entre la France et
l'Italie il est soutenu sans ambiguïté
par le gouvernement je le redis le
projet de Lyon-Turin est un projet que
nous soutenons qui est nécessaire qui
est très attendu des deux côtés des
Alpes près de 1 million de poids lourds
pourront être basculer sur le rail c'est
une nécessité écologique vous l'avez
rappelé madame la députée c'est donc un
projet structurant pour notre pays un
autre continent nous sommes le seul pays
à ne pas avoir ce type de tunnel c'est
très important de également de le
rappeler il comprend aussi la partie
nord du contournement ferroviaire de
l'agglomération lyonnaise qu'il est
important de soulager vous je vous sais
aussi très soucieuse sur les
financements le financement notamment du
projet c'est donc un total de 10
milliards d'euros dont nous parlons dont
environ 6 milliards d'euros qui restent
à financer en prenant en compte la
participation attendue de l'Union
européenne sur ce sujet le ministre des
Transports Clément Beaune a été
extrêmement clair l'État est prêt à
prendre la moitié donc soit 3 milliards
d'euros c'est un engagement majeur et
désormais nous attendons aussi des
collectivités locales qu'elles puissent
abonder pour arriver au montant global
sachez que nous sommes totalement
mobilisés à la réalisation de ce projet
et qu'il est nécessaire évidemment pour
réduire les émissions de gaz à effet de
serre qui sont également insupportables
dans le dans le sur le territoire merci
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à madame Béatrice Bel-Ami
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Jean-Christophe Combre
ministre des Solidarités de l'autonomie
et des personnes handicapées monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je souhaite
aujourd'hui vous alerter sur la
situation inquiétante des structures
d'accueil des personnes âgées
médicalisés ou non du secteur public ou
associatif nos EHPAD nos résidences
autonomies sont en danger je l'ai déjà
exprimé ici même le 13 décembre dernier
de nombreux élus gestionnaires des pads
ou de résidences autonomie et
particulièrement ceux de la Vendée
s'inquiète quant à l'avenir de leur
structure les finances sont très
inquiétantes et les trésorerie au plus
bas voire négatives les difficultés de
recrutement sont inédites l'inquiétude
est au plus haut pour cet été dans ma
circonscription plusieurs mers ont
alerté sur leurs difficultés face au
manque de personnel on fait manger les
résidents dans leur chambre pour
optimiser les temps de travail
éviter les transferts certaines
structures menacent de fermer pour les
trois mois d'été seront-elles en
capacité de rouvrir d'autres mobilisent
des lignes de trésorerie qui auront leur
limite dans mon département monsieur le
ministre le taux de chômage est au plus
bas 5% et je m'en réjouis mais la
conséquence du manque de bras devient
difficile à juguler un manque criant sur
les métiers de l'humain et du grand âge
face à ces difficultés les leviers
financiers et RH mobilisables sont
souvent des vœux pieux les ARS locales
et les départements sont tout aussi
démunis la réponse ne peut venir que de
l'État et elle est urgente j'ai bien
conscience qu'aucune mesure ne pourra
solutionner les difficultés de
recrutement en quelques semaines aussi
Monsieur le Ministre pouvez-vous nous
indiquer quelles sont les nouvelles
mesures envisagées pour mieux
accompagner nos structures je vous
remercie je vous remercie mes chers
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Christophe con ministre des
Solidarités de l'autonomie et des
personnes handicapées merci
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Bel-Ami je vous remercie pour votre
question et permettez-moi comme je le
fais régulièrement de commencer ma
réponse en félicitant et en remerciant
l'ensemble des personnels qui sont
aujourd'hui engagés dans nos
établissements pour protéger et
accompagner nos aînés ils le font à la
force de leur engagement dans des
conditions qui sont souvent comme vous
l'avez décrit particulièrement difficile
et je suis à leur côté en particulier en
ce moment pour préparer cette période
estivale qui sera à n'en pas douter
difficile les mobiliser et leur
permettre de traverser c'est moi qui
seront extrêmement tendus vous dire
également que le Conseil national de la
refondation dédiée ou bien vieillir a
remis ses conclusions et je présenterai
dans quelques jours un plan une feuille
de route du dédiée au Bien Vieillir qui
permettra d'apporter des réponses
structurelles à la situation que
connaissent aujourd'hui ces
établissements dans laquelle chacun ces
établissements devra trouver sa place
que ce soit les EHPAD que ce soit les
résidences autonomies ou que ce soit
toutes les solutions intermédiaires qui
sont attendues par nos concitoyens les
la situation financière que vous
décrivez nous la connaissons nous
l'avons anticipé déléguer près de 500
millions d'euros de crédit
supplémentaire en fin d'année j'ai
mobilisé les ARS aux côtés des
départements pour suivre la situation de
chaque établissement et je le redis nous
ne laisserons aucun établissement sur le
bord du chemin on a triplé les crédits
non reconductibles cette année pour
s'assurer des difficultés de trésorerie
les dépenses les réponses structurelles
elles viendront comme je vous l'ai dit
dans la feuille de route dédiée au Bien
Vieillir on apportera des réponses à la
question de l'attractivité des métiers
évidemment pour pouvoir renforcer le
taux d'encadrement dans les
établissements et on apportera aussi des
réponses structurelles quand à au modèle
économique de ces structures que ce soit
les résidences autonomies ou les EHPAD
je sais que la mission conduite par
Madame pires Boone qui rendra ses
conclusions madame la Première ministre
dans quelques jours
nous permettra d'apporter des réponses
encore une fois structurelles
la parole est à Monsieur Joris Beauvais
pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse au ministre de l'économie et
des finances monsieur le ministre nous
sommes le 20 juin cela signifie que
depuis 10 jours un tiers des Français
n'ont plus que 100 euros maximum de
reste à vivre sur leur compte en banque
100 euros pour manger faire le plein à
les travailler entretenir son véhicule
100 euros seulement pour toutes ces
dépenses pourtant si essentielles trois
Français sur 5 on réduit leur dépenses
alimentaires faute de moyens un Français
sur deux saute des repas 40% repose des
soins et ça sera sans doute aggravé
suite aux dernières annonces la liste de
l'inacceptable est longue et pourtant
vous minimisez la détresse dans laquelle
se trouve tous ces Français ne pas
pouvoir payer ses factures se retrouver
à découvert c'est une charge mentale
énorme pour ceux qui vivent ces
situations anxiété troubles du sommeil
dépression et même penser suicidaire
vont de pair avec ces difficultés
financières monsieur le ministre vous
allez me répondre vous allez me répondre
que vous entendez les inquiétudes
mais les Français ne sont pas dupe de
votre enfumage trois quarts d'entre eux
jugent que vous ne faites pas assez pour
lutter contre l'inflation les Français
attendent que vous écoutiez et que vous
nous écoutiez leur représentants que
nous sommes depuis un an dans cette
émission les députés du rassemblement
national réclament ces mesures fortes
pour le pouvoir d'achat des Français
baisser la TVA sur les énergies et les
carburants supprimer la TVA sur les 100
produits de première nécessité avec ces
deux mesures c'est entre 150 et 200
euros par mois que vous rendez aux
Français dans quelques jours nous serons
en juillet et les départs en vacances
débuteront mais la moitié des français
n'auront pas ce plaisir une année de
plus parce que parce qu'il faut composer
avec les prix du carburant des péages et
tout ce qui va avec Monsieur le Ministre
quand allez-vous décider de prendre les
mesures efficaces pour permettre pour
permettre à tous nos concitoyens de
sortir la tête de l'eau je vous remercie
merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Olivia Grégoire
ministre délégué chargé des petites et
moyennes entreprises du commerce de
l'artisanat et du tourisme merci madame
la présidente depuis un an c'est la même
question
je repensais à un grand auteur que je
vous recommande depuis un an c'est la
même chanson c'est toujours la même
chanson la seule différence c'est que
nous nous agissons parce que vous n'avez
rien voté et quand on parle d'enfumage
il faut être précis on écoute la
ministre vous n'avez rien voté depuis un
an pour soulager le pouvoir d'achat des
Français rien ni le bouclier tarifaire
ni l'aide exceptionnelle de rentrer ni
la revalorisation des bourses ni la
revalorisation des aPL ni l'indemnité
carburant vous n'avez rien voté je
pourrais vous rappeler que nous avons
mis 46 mill sur le bouclier tarifaire
pour soulager la douloureuse de nos
compatriotes je pourrais vous rappeler
que nous avons mis en place un trimestre
anti-inflation mais s'il vous plaît s'il
vous plaît que nous avons mis en place
un trimestre entier inflation qui
démontre que les prix Brest je pourrais
vous rappeler que nous avons sollicité
les industriels pour qu'en ce moment
même les prix soient en train de baisser
mais vous le rassemblement national vous
en un an une seule proposition vous
n'aimez pas que je vous le rappelle une
seule proposition pour soulager le
pouvoir d'achat une proposition qui
coûterait 10 milliards d'euros ont
contribuable une proposition qui ne
fournirait aucun effet aux consommateurs
quand on parle d'enfumage vous savez de
quoi vous parlez rendez-vous la semaine
prochaine une énième question sur la TVA
c'est toujours la même chanson en
attendant nous agissons merci merci
beaucoup madame la ministre monsieur
Beauvais
madame le ministre vous dites nous
n'avons pas de solution rien que là nous
vous en avons proposé déjà deux
l'enfumage c'est bien vous est-ce que
vous avez déjà essayé de survivre avec
le SMIC peut-être pas moi oui merci
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Chantal
[Musique]
s'il vous plaît
la parole est à Madame Chantal Jourdan
pour le groupe socialiste
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à madame la ministre délégué
chargé des personnes handicapées selon
Luna pays
47000 personnes en situation de handicap
en France sont sans solution d'accueil
dont 8 000 enfants qui se voient privés
de leurs droits de l'éducation suite à
une réclamation déposée par le réseau
une API APF France handicap une infâme
et avec le concours de la Commission
nationale des droits de l'homme et de la
Défenseur des droits auprès du Comité
des droits sociaux du Conseil de
l'Europe la France s'est vu notifié ses
grands manquements en matière
d'accompagnement de service de soutien
de justice socio-économique d'accès au
logement d'accès à la santé et à la
scolarisation tout simplement ce sont
les droits des personnes en situation de
handicap et de leur famille qui sont
bafouis le président de la République
qui a fait des annonces lors de la
Conférence nationale du handicap nous a
présenté des mesures qui constituent une
juste continuation des efforts à
conduire néanmoins de nombreuses
associations dénoncent un manque de
transparence qui voile une réelle
ambition de société inclusive cette
vision que nous appelons de nos vœux
aurait nécessité donc clarifier les
contours et de proposer un plan plus
réel nous devrions y trouver la
définition de l'école de demain pour
tous les enfants en situation de
handicap aux côtés des autres des moyens
financiers en relation avec des étapes
bien identifiées du projet inclusif
l'évolution de nouvelles articulations
entre les structures médico-sociales
l'éducados l'éducation nationale et le
monde du travail le projet de
transformation des métiers
d'accompagnement leur juste
reconnaissance et les recrutements
nécessaires
pour commencer il est urgent de se
pencher sur les besoins imminents des
enfants aujourd'hui sans solution
scolaire ou bien mal scolarisées comme
le signal le Conseil de l'Europe je
pense merci je pense particulièrement
aux Ulis qui sont insuffisantes et je
demande quelle mesure efficiente pour
l'argent collègue merci la parole est à
Geneviève Darius sec ministre délégué
chargé des personnes handicapées
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
je vous remercie de votre question parce
qu'elle permet de mettre le focus sur
quelque chose qui nous tient à cœur
particulièrement
c'est
l'inclusion et l'inclusion est un mot
que je n'aime pas beaucoup parce que il
est toujours à sens unique et que en
définitive la philosophie de l'inclusion
c'est aussi que notre société devienne
inclusive que nous lutions contre les
clichés les stéréotypes et que notre
société connaisse mieux ce qu'est le
handicap afin d'accepter aussi de
comprendre quels sont les sujets et
quels sont les besoins des personnes en
situation de handicap bien sûr lors de
la Conférence nationale du handicap le
président de la République a lancé des
mesures fortes des mesures fortes dans
l'accessibilité point qui est en retard
dans notre pays à tous les niveaux et
puis des mesures fortes en termes de de
création de solutions d'accompagnement
comme vous le demandiez auprès de tous
les public S qui en ont besoin ces
pratiquesment pour ces solutions
d'accompagnement 2 milliards d'euros qui
seront mis sur la table que nous allons
décliner en
d'étalement pluriannuel afin de donner
de la visibilité à ces solutions et que
nous travaillerons avec chaque président
de conseil départemental afin que
effectivement
la structuration de de tous les de
toutes les offres pour les personnes en
situation de handicap soit adaptées aux
besoins des territoires moi je voulais
vous dire aussi quand même que nous
avons un biais et un manque nous
manquons de donner de donner consolidées
à l'échelle de tous les territoires et
j'ai lancé une grande un grand appel à
tous les acteurs du secteur afin de
pouvoir avoir ces données nationales et
départementales qui nous aideront à
donner consolider qui nous aideront à
construire ces solutions sachez que nous
souhaitons vraiment et j'étais à l'ONU
la semaine dernière j'ai parlé de droit
j'ai parlé d'effectivité des droits et
nous sommes tout à fait en phase avec
ces objectifs merci beaucoup madame la
ministre la parole est à Madame Patricia
Lemoine par le groupe Renaissance
identique ma question s'adresse à Madame
Dominique Faure ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité madame la ministre dans un 21e
siècle qui a eu tendance à favoriser
l'urbain nombre de nos ruralités luttent
pour éviter leur déclin elle lutte pour
accueillir un médecin pour maintenir
leur école pour attirer des commerces ou
créer une ligne de bus qui bénéficiera à
tout un bassin de vie parce qu'elle
concerne un habitant sur trois et 9
communes sur 10 en France les ruralités
sont au cœur des préoccupations du
président de la République et du
gouvernement depuis 2017
Service Public Numérique mobilité santé
commerce logement sont autant de sujets
pour lesquels des solutions concrètes
ont d'ores et déjà été déployés à
travers notamment l'agenda rural la
création de la NCT les maisons France
service ou encore le plan France très
haut débit
l'année 2023 marque un nouveau tournant
dans cette ambition avec l'annonce il y
a quelques jours du plan France ruralité
articulé autour de quatre grands axes
concernant l'axe lune numéro 3 il est
prévu plusieurs mesures visant à
répondre aux problématiques les plus
tenaces à travers notamment le
déploiement de 100 médicaux bus pour
faire face à la désertification médicale
la pérennisation du Fonds de soutien au
commerce ruraux avec un abondement de 36
millions d'euros sur trois ans ou encore
le fond pour les mobilités du dernier
kilomètre doté de 90 millions d'euros
également sur trois ans les habitants
des territoires ruraux seront
particulièrement attentifs au
déploiement de ces dispositifs notamment
sur notre capacité à attirer des
médecins volontaires pour exercer dans
ces médicaments
la ministre pouvez-vous ainsi nous
préciser comment se déclineront ces
mesures particulièrement attendu par les
élus ruraux je vous remercie je vous
remercie ma chère collègues
la parole est à Madame Dominique Faure
ministre délégué chargé des
collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la député
Lemoine je veux saluer le travail qui a
été réalisé par la fois Jacqueline
Gouraud et Joël Giraud sur l'agenda
rural comme vous l'avez dit c'est
plusieurs milliards plusieurs milliards
qui ont été investis ces dernières
années et il est vrai que cet agenda
poursuit son développement et continue à
délivrer un certain de services il nous
est apparu ces 9 derniers mois l'absolu
nécessité de le prolonger et de
l'amplifier vous avez effectivement mis
l'accent sur cet axe 3 que je trouve
très intéressant parce qu'il met les
femmes et les hommes qui vivent en
ruralité au cœur de notre politique
publique alors vous avez cité
effectivement les 100 médicaux bus c'est
des généralistes c'est aussi des
spécialistes qui vont pouvoir aller vers
aller vers les habitants de nos
ruralités le comment mais c'est tout
simplement se rapprocher du préfet
puisque l'accent c'est de l'ingénierie
il y aura des chefs de projets
ingénierie qui seront donc aux côtés des
préfets et qui viendront répondre aux
demandes que les mères en ruralité
solliciteront sur ces médicaments c'est
100 médicaux bus avant fin 2024 qui
seront déployés et ce sera à la main des
préfets ensuite vous évoquez le commerce
rural et effectivement je veux souligner
le fait que ce sont des vrais liens
lieux de liens social et à quel point
aujourd'hui avec jusqu'à 80 000 € qui
peut être investi dans ces commerces de
proximité avec Olivier agrégoire c'est
pas moins de 12 millions donc 36
millions d'euros que nous avons mis pour
nos ruralités qui vont se déployer sur
les trois années qui viennent et puis
sur la mobilité pas moins de 30 millions
et donc 90 millions d'euros sur les
trois ans qui viennent pour cette
mobilité du dernier kilomètre faire en
sorte que l'on puisse se rendre à la
gare que l'on puisse se rendre au
dernier arrêt de bus comment
procède-t-on et bien tout simplement par
l'intermédiaire de ces chefs de projets
interlocuteurs ruralité auprès du préfet
parce que tous les maires de ces
villages ruraux que j'ai rencontrés
m'ont dit que c'était là qu'ils avaient
besoin de cette ingénierie nous allons
aussi servir les intercommunalités parce
qu'elles sont AOM en matière de mobilité
je vous remercie merci beaucoup madame
la ministre la parole est à Monsieur
Damien Maudet pour le groupe la France
insoumise
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à Monsieur le Ministre de la
Santé François Brown mais tout d'abord
j'ai une pensée pour les soignants des
hôpitaux en grève aujourd'hui ils ont de
quoi voici ce qu'il nous disent quand un
patient arrive Jean fait quoi je mets où
je lui donne sa chance ou pas il faut
que je fasse des choix aujourd'hui dire
venez aux urgences vous serez bien pris
en charge c'est un mensonge ces mots ces
alertes n'importe quel député les
entendra s'il va dans l'hôpital près de
chez lui en Limousin en Alsace en
Bretagne en Île-de-France aux quatre
coins du pays l'hôpital public est en
voie d'effondrement monsieur le ministre
un an que vous êtes là et tout à empirer
80% des aides-soignants jusque leur
condition de travail se sont dégradées
80% sont en burn out et un infirmier sur
3 soit démissionner avant la fin de
l'année tous les pires records sont
battus pourtant dans une interview
récente vous avez dit que vous abordez
les choses avec sérénité cet hiver des
médecins ont dû intubé des enfants dans
les couloirs faute de place faute de
personnel faute de lit et vous vous êtes
serein les urgences sont saturés alors
vous les fermez parfois le jour souvent
la nuit mais vous vous êtes serein mais
le pire des patients attendent des
heures sur des brancards certains
meurent sur des brancards comme ça était
le cas à Rouen selon votre ancien
syndicat ça murgence de France 150
serait décédé faute de prise en charge
mais vous vous êtes serein
monsieur le ministre la vérité c'est
dites nous combien combien de cas de
burn-out chez les soignants combien de
drames humains combien de décès ou
faudra-t-il avant de vous inquiéter pour
vous faire combien il en faudra pour
vous faire réagir la vérité c'est que
vous êtes serein vous coûte parce que
vous continuez d'annoncer des économies
des hausses de frais pour les patients
l'enfer pour les soignants parce que
vous vous demandez jamais de lit vous et
l’élite du pays vous trouverez toujours
une clinique un médecin pour vous faire
soigner quitte à payer monsieur le
ministre dites-le êtes-vous en train de
créer une santé à deux vitesses dont
personne ne veut monsieur le ministre
nous avions le meilleur système de santé
du monde rendez le nous
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur François Braun ministre de la
Santé de la prévention
Monsieur et Madame merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député modé
heureusement que nous n'avions pas
attendu votre alerte pour nous occuper
de l'hôpital public et des soignants
alors vous revenez sans cesse sur les
crises que nous avons eu cette hiver sur
des enfants entre la vie et la mort dans
les couloirs d'hôpital ce qui n'était
pas le cas je vous rassure moi je vais
aussi vous parler de l'hôpital public
monsieur le député parce que savez-vous
je le connais un petit peu quand même
l'hôpital public c'est aussi ce monsieur
je vous donnerai pas son nom de 65 ans
la semaine dernière qui fait brutalement
une paralysie sa femme appelle le SAMU
les urgences et oui ça existe ça
fonctionne il est conduit à l'hôpital il
a une IRM qui est lu à distance par le
neurologue du CHU qui confirme l'AVC qui
lui donne l'indication d'injecter un
produit qui va déboucher son caillot et
une heure après il n'a plus de paralysie
c'est ça aussi notre hôpital public ce
ne sont pas que des situations
catastrophiques et j'en profite pour
rendre hommage pour rendre assez
soignants qui sont là tous les jours
toutes les nuits pour s'occuper de nos
patientes alors oui cette majorité
travaille pour l'hôpital public investi
dans l'hôpital 19 milliards du Ségur
d'investissement investi pour les
soignants et vous le savez mon objectif
principal c'est d'améliorer leur qualité
de vie au travail de diminuer toutes les
contraintes administratives de facilité
le travail à l'échelle de service de
sortir de la tarification à l'activité
tout ça peut vous paraître peut-être
très technique mais c'est comme ça que
nous sortirons des difficultés de
l'hôpital public et ce à quoi s'engage
ce gouvernement merci beaucoup monsieur
le ministre monsieur le député
j'ai pas eu le sentiment d'avoir
réellement une réponse si ce n'est que
vous ne dit qu'à l'hôpital public on
soigne et bien c'est justement parce
qu'on veut que l'hôpital public les gens
puissent soigner qu'il faut investir
monsieur le ministre il faut sauver
l'hôpital et c'est vous qui l'avez dit
l'hôpital est à l'agonie il est temps de
le sauver où est l'ancien syndicaliste
que vous étiez monsieur Braun
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Mathieu Mathieu
Marco pour le rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse aux ministres délégué au
transport en annonçant la liquidation de
fret SNCF vous avez obéi aux injonctions
de la Commission européenne qui a ouvert
une enquête pour 5,3 milliards d'euros
d'adversée à l'entreprise ce qui ne
serait pas conforme aux règles
européennes de la concurrence une fois
de plus l'idéologie ultralibérale
bruxelloise et ses fidèles supplétifs au
gouvernement vont casser une entreprise
publique l'ouverture à la concurrence du
fret n'aura pas eu les bénéfices
attendus et c'est le moins qu'on puisse
dire la part des marchandises
transportées par rail à diminué de
moitié entre 2006 et 2019 dans la gare
de triage à Somain chez moi dans le Nord
c'est 500 emplois qui ont été supprimés
en 15 ans quel résultat catastrophique
dans un territoire qui n'avait vraiment
pas besoin de ça songer à l'absurdité
d'un système où au nom des règles
européennes la SNCF a été découpée en
filiales et ou SNCF réseau
refusent des sillons à SNCF fret nuisant
fortement à son activité c'est le
serpent qui se mord la queue le tout
avec l'argent des Français la réalité
c'est que derrière vos belles promesses
s'appelant à la relance du fret c'est
vous les euro béats macronistes élus de
gauche et de droite confondus qui ont
cassé le frais de ferroviaire et laissés
sur le carreau des centaines d'agents
dans le Nord comme ailleurs à Somain un
poste à brûler il y a un an et demi ce
qui rend inutilisable tout un chantier
plus de la moitié des voix sont fermées
deviennent impraticables par manque
d'entretien un million d'euros seraient
nécessaire pour remettre en état à la
gare de triage au niveau national au nom
de tous ces ouvriers agents de fret
entreprises une nouvelle fois cassée
quand allez-vous œuvrer pour que les
États membres de l'Union européenne
retrouvent leur souveraineté en termes
de transport et dans le Nord quand
allez-vous investir dans la gare de
triage de Somain pour la sauver merci
merci beaucoup mon cher collègue la
parole est à Madame Bérengère
illard ministre rechargé de l'écologie
merci et madame la Présidente Mesdames
et Messieurs les Députés monsieur le
député marchiau le fret ferroviaire en
particulier public reste un secteur
stratégique auquel le gouvernement et la
majorité sont extrêmement attachés au
moins autant que vous et votre groupe
vous l'avez rappelé en janvier 2023 la
Commission européenne a ouvert une
procédure formelle sur les conditions de
financement de l'activité du fret et de
la SNCF nous avons travaillé et nous
continuons à le faire dans un esprit de
responsabilité loin de toute démagogie
facile et sur ce sujet extrêmement
important c'est pour cela plutôt que de
prendre le risque de voir disparaître le
frais de ferroviaire français dans les
mois qui viennent nous assumons de
travailler en lien avec la commission
vers la mise en place d'une
discontinuité raisonnable je ne vous
laisse pas dire que nous bradons le fret
SNCF ou que nous cédons au diktak de
Bruxelles nous avons ici marqué trois
lignes rouges la première pas de
licenciement pas de privatisation et pas
de report modal sur la route celle-ci
seront tenues pour garantir la
continuité de son exploitation
on sera très prochainement un nouvel
appel à manifestation d'intérêt pour
identifier un repreneur le train des
primeurs qui a été sauvé par l'État en
2021 continuera de rouler quel que soit
la nouvelle étiquette de l'opérateur
tout ceci se fait dans un contexte que
je souhaite rappeler qui est celui d'une
accélération de l'État dans les
infrastructures dédiées au fret Clément
Beaune ainsi annoncé 4 milliards d'euros
d'investissement d'ici 2032 qui est la
déclinaison pour le frais de ferroviaire
du plan d'avenir pour les transports qui
a été annoncé par la première ministre
en février dernier les aides à
l'exploitation accordée pendant le plan
de relance seront augmentés d'ici la fin
2024 à 200 millions d'euros et seront
également prolongés jusqu'en 2030 vous
voyez monsieur le député le gouvernement
est totalement mobilisé
merci beaucoup madame la ministre
monsieur le député derrière ce blabla
technocratique c'est 20% de l'activité
qui risque d'être supprimé par la
liquidation de fret SNCF et 500 emplois
supprimés
je vous remercie
la parole est à Monsieur Nicolas
turquois pour le groupe démocrate
merci madame la Présidente mes chers
collègues ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre du Travail du plein
emploi et de l'insertion le Conseil
d'orientation des retraites le corps
doit adopter ce rapport annuel jeudi 22
juin il a transmis les éléments à ses
membres et la presse de ce jour sans
fait largement les côtes le moins que
l'on puisse dire c'est que ce nouveau
rapport questionne il y a quelques mois
le corps évoquait des éventuels
déficites de nos régimes de retraite de
l'ordre de l'épaisseur du trait son
président évoquait même en septembre
dernier ouvrait les guillemets les
résultats de ce rapport ne valide pas le
bien fondé des discours qui mettent en
avant l'idée d'une dynamique non
contrôlée des dépenses de retraite
fermer les guillemets et ainsi de
contester l'intérêt d'un report de l'âge
légal de départ à la retraite
les conclusions apparaissent jeudi font
le constat à peu près inverse
si le rapport salue aussi les effets
positifs de la réforme pour les plus
petites pensions et notamment celle des
femmes le groupe démocrate s'interroge
sur les raisons de se renversement
d'analyse quasi complet
le Haut-Commissariat aux plans mais
pourtant clairement pointé difficile
structurel de l'ordre de 30 milliards
d'euros mais les oppositions avaient
préféré relayer les doutes émis par le
Conseil d'Orientation alimentant ainsi
la contestation sociale
notre système de retraite a besoin d'un
pilotage efficace basé sur des analyses
responsables et objectives
manifestement cela n'a pas été le cas il
convient d'en tirer des enseignements au
groupe démocrate nous souhaiterions tout
d'abord que les partenaires sociaux
soient davantage associés au pilotage du
régime général des retraites à l'instar
de la gestion d'agir Carco qui a fait
ses preuves et nous pensons aussi qu'une
réflexion doit être menée sur le
fonctionnement ou le dysfonctionnement
du Conseil d'orientation des retraites
nous aimerions donc monsieur le ministre
connaître votre position sur ces sujets
je vous remercie je vous remercie la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier du soft
ministre du Travail du plein emploi et
de l'insertion
[Musique]
merci à madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député Tourcoing vous m'interrogez sur
le rapport que le Conseil d'orientation
des retraites aura examiné demain
puisque comme vous l'avez dit les
documents qui sont publiés sont en
termes de pré rapport distribués aux
membres en attendant son examen je
comprends votre surprise et je comprends
vos interrogations d'abord parce qu'il y
a quelques mois vous l'avez dit le
président du même Conseil d'orientation
des retraites expliquait que pour le
citer il n'y avait pas le feu au lac le
déficit serait de l'épaisseur du trait
aujourd'hui c'est une once de déficit un
montant assez conséquent puisque ce pré
rapport évoque le chiffre de 8 milliards
d'euros l'interrogation est d'autant
plus légitime qu'il y a cinq ans en 2017
c'est un peu le même phénomène que nous
avions vécu avec des prévisions
radicalement différentes à six mois
d'intervalle ce qui ne manque pas
d'interroger sur les outils dont nous
disposons pour piloter le système de
retraite nous avons deux enseignements
que nous pouvons tirer de ce rapport
pour ce que nous en connaissons et dans
l'attente de son examen le premier
enseignement et que si nous n'avions pas
fait cette réforme le déficit serait
encore bien plus sup érieur que ce
qu'annonce le corps puisque celles et
ceux qui nous disaient il y a quelques
semaines qu'il n'y avait pas de déficit
10 dans le même rapport que sans la
réforme ce serait 20 milliards d'euros
de déficit en 2030 alors que nous-mêmes
avions anticipé un déficit autour de 13
milliards d'euros cela confirme donc le
bien-fondé de la réforme ça confirme sa
nécessité pour sauver le système par
répartition et ça confirme le courage
qui ont eu tous les députés tous les
sénateurs qui ont soutenu cette démarche
historiquement la deuxième
le deuxième enseignement c'est que cette
réforme produit ses premiers effets et
dans ce rapport nous voyons que la
réforme va permettre d'une part de
garantir le système par répartition va
tenir compte de la poussée
inflationniste c'est ce qui explique la
dégradation mais cela montre aussi que
la réforme permet de mieux traiter de
mieux accompagner ces et ceux qui ont
des carrières longues celles et ceux qui
ont des carrières hachés et va permettre
25% de salariés les plus modestes
d'avoir une retraite plus importante et
lorsqu'on regarde les choses de manière
un peu projet prospective la génération
84 grâce à ce rapport aura une retraite
10% supérieur à ce que le réussite nous
n'avons rien fait c'est ça démonte que
sans la réforme les retraites t'auraient
baissé deuxième raison d'avoir une
raison de faire cette réforme
[Musique]
la parole est à Madame Nathalie bassière
pour le groupe yote merci madame la
Présidente ma question s'adresse à
monsieur le ministre délégué chargé de
la ville et du Logement monsieur le
ministre une crise du logement touche
l'Hexagone mais encore plus les
outre-mer une crise grave ce profil à la
Réunion il n'y a plus suffisamment de
toi pour tous les Réunionnais les
annonces du gouvernement début juin sur
la fin du dispositif Pinel en 2024 et
son nom remplacement une première depuis
40 ans quand même vont avoir à la
Réunion un effet négatif démultiplié je
vous rappelle que notre île subit une
forte pression démographique avec une
population actuellement de plus de 860
000 habitants qui va tendre vers le
million d'ici 10 à 15 ans mettre
l'accent sur la rénovation du locatif ne
suffira pas pour notre territoire et
notre population la crise sanitaire a
entraîné l'arrêt des chantiers la crise
internationale et ses conséquences
notamment l'explosion du coût des
matériaux de construction mettent les
entreprises du BTP à genoux
à la pression démographique s'ajoute une
raréfaction de l'offre de logement HT
walloué en cause spéculation immobilière
augmentation des prix des et des loyers
résultant de la présence croissante des
non réunionnais
os des taux d'intérêts rigueur des
banques conversion de nombreux logements
en location saisonnière cela pose de
nombreux problèmes difficultés pour de
jeunes Réunionnais à des cohabiter pour
s'installer seul ou en couple et cela
génère des tensions latentes on pourrait
débattre de l'efficacité et des effets
pervers des dispositifs tels que le
Girardin outremer autrefois ou le Pinel
outremer mais aujourd'hui retirez la
dernière incitation fiscale à
l'investissement locatif dans le neuf
équivaut à sacrifier les professionnels
de la construction et de l'immobilier et
surtout les Réunionnais victimes du fort
déséquilibre offre demande au marché
immobilier monsieur le ministre je vous
le demande solennellement quelle mesure
spécifique le gouvernement va-t-il
rapidement prendre pour éviter une grave
crise du logement dans les territoires
d'outre-mer et faire de la Réunion une
île de propriétaire réunionnais je vous
remercie merci beaucoup ma chère
collègues la parole est à Monsieur
Olivier Klein ministre délégué chargé de
la ville et du logement
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Nathalie Bassir votre question me donne
l'occasion de rappeler les annonces
fortes qu'a fait la première ministre
lors de son déplacement à la Réunion
l'intervention amplifiée de Lama le
passage du net de 30 à 50 % sur la
réhabilitation la décision qui a été
prise de détendre la totalité du crédit
d'impôt au logement social comme vous
l'avez rappelé qui était une demande
très forte et justifiée des bailleurs
sociaux de la Réunion mais de l'ensemble
des territoires d'outre-mer et cette
décision a été a été faite l'extension
de ma prime rénov copropriété et de ma
prime adapte bien évidemment sur les
territoires d'outre-mer je commence par
ça parce que bien évidemment en
outre-mer comme sur l'ensemble du
territoire hexagonal nous avons à
privilégier le parcours résidentiel et
privilégier la réhabilitation du
logement déjà là la première des
réponses à la crise du logement c'est le
logement déjà là ensuite oui vous avez
raison il faut accompagner le
développement du logement à la Réunion
en outre-mer sur le territoire hexagonal
nous avons fait le choix de supprimer
une niche fiscale une niche fiscale
excusez moi qui est aujourd'hui qui a
montré son efficacité qui a créé des
logements parfois de piètre qualité des
copropriétés qui sont souvent des
copropriétés aujourd'hui en situation de
fragilité et oui nous faisons le choix
du logement intermédiaire du logement
locatif intermédiaire avec des des
entreprises qui gèrent ces logements qui
les gèrent mieux et c'est cette accent
que nous allons mettre en augmentant le
zonage de possibilités de faire du
logement intermédiaire y compris bien
évidemment dans nos territoires
d'outre-mer pour avoir des
institutionnels qui vont mieux gérer ce
logement ensuite nous continuerons dans
le cadre du travail que nous menons avec
le ministre des Outre-mer a développé le
logement en outre-mer avec les
partenaires et en particulier l'usage
dans le cadre du pacte de confiance que
nous allons bientôt signer je n'en doute
pas merci merci beaucoup monsieur le
ministre la parole est à Monsieur Paul
midi pour le comprenez ça merci madame
la Présidente ma question s'adresse
monsieur Jean-Noël barreau ministre
délégué chargé de la transition
numérique et des télécommunications le
salon vivatech a eu lieu la semaine
dernière c'est le plus grand salon
d'Europe dédié aux start-up et à la tech
il faut le rappeler nos startups et nos
peines innovantes représentent
maintenant une part très importante de
notre économie un million et demi
d'emplois mais surtout un tiers de notre
capacité à atteindre le plein emploi
avec la création de 300 000 à 500 000
emplois dans les prochaines années à
l'occasion de vivatech le président de
la République a fait quatre annonces
très importantes pour être un des pays
leaders de l'intelligence artificielle
il a annoncé des investissements massifs
pour doubler le nombre de formations Mia
ou renforcé par exemple nos capacités de
calcul avec le futur calculateur
exascale sur le plan du financement et
alors que les levées de fonds ont
ralenti depuis plusieurs mois le
président a annoncé la mobilisation de 7
milliards d'euros auprès des assureurs
grâce à l'initiative tibit 2
pour aider nos plus jeunes startups le
président a aussi annoncé reprendre la
principale mesure du rapport que je vous
ai remis la semaine dernière il s'agit
du Dispositif Jeunes Entreprises
refontent et renforcements du dispositif
j ei qui doit permettre de soutenir deux
fois plus de jeunes entreprises
innovantes et les aider à embaucher à
lever des fonds grâce à des mécanismes
d'incitation fiscaux des particuliers
les aider en trésorerie et accéder à la
commande publique cette mesure doit
permettre de générer un milliard d'euros
par an de financement supplémentaires et
créer 100000 emplois d'ici 2027 le
président a aussi annoncé le lancement
du programme d'accompagnement French
tech 2030 pour nos meilleures startups
industriels et dipthèques françaises
enfin monsieur le ministre vous avez
annoncé un plan ambitieux et concret
pour renforcer la commande publique et
privée à destination nos startups je
choisis la french tech aussi Monsieur le
Ministre pourriez-vous nous préciser
l'horizon de mise en oeuvre de ces
annonces très attendues ainsi que
l'impact envisagé merci beaucoup
merci beaucoup la parole est à Monsieur
Jean-Noël Barrault ministre délégué
chargé de la transition numérique et des
télécommunications merci madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés monsieur le député vous l'avez
dit la 7e édition de vivatech avec ses
150000 visiteurs a été un grand succès
et je tiens à remercier toutes celles et
ceux qui ont participé à son
organisation un succès qui nous rappelle
que depuis 8 ans et la première édition
de vivatex sous l'impulsion du Président
de la République la France a renoué avec
sa nature profonde de grande nation
d'innovation et d'entrepreneuriat la
France a créé des dizaines de milliers
d'entreprises innantes qui elle-même ont
créé des centaines de milliers d'emplois
dans tous les territoires de métropole
et d'outre-mer à cette occasion à
l'occasion du latex la première ministre
a annoncé 9 nouveaux programmes de
formation à la cyber aux cantiques au
verdissement du numérique et lancer un
programme TEC pour toute qui va
permettre dès la rentrée d'accompagner
10000 jeunes filles vers les métiers du
numérique à cette occasion le président
de la République a fait annonce majeure
dont nous allons veiller avec Bruno Le
Maire à la mise en œuvre dans les
prochains mois des annonces majeures sur
l'intelligence artificielle et le
métaver qui vont s'inviter dans nos vies
quotidiennes et que la France doit
maîtriser coûte que coûte des
engagements qui vont se concrétiser très
prochainement des engagements majeurs
pour poursuivre pour prolonger les forts
engagés depuis 10 ans et la création de
la French Tech pour permettre aux
entreprises innovantes dans notre pays
de bénéficier de financement
d'accompagnement et de clients de
financement avec les propositions de
votre rapport qui seront examinés au
projet de loi de finance avec
l'initiative tibi et la Fédération des
des assureurs pour investir au capital
des entreprises d'innovation et ses
engagements se sont concrétisés dès la
semaine prochaine l'accompagnement avec
le programme que vous avez cité 125
entreprises issues de tous les
territoires de France au 2/3 de la
recherche publique et à 30% fondé par
des femmes et puis des clients avec
cette initiative qui rassemble des
centaines d'entreprises des une
cinquantaine d'acteurs institutionnels
qui engagent pour faire doubler le
recours aux solutions de la startup
d'ici des startups d'ici 2027 vous
l'aurez compris monsieur le député le
gouvernement agira résolument pour faire
en sorte que la France maîtrise ses
technologies d'avenir et qu'elle les
mette au service des Français merci
Monsieur le Ministre
la parole est à Madame Catherine
couturier pour le gros plat France
insoumise
merci
merci madame la Présidente collègue ma
question s'adresse à Monsieur Olivier
Véran porte-parole du gouvernement est
chargé du renouveau démocratique dans un
entretien au Figaro Richard Ferrand
déclaré regretté tout ce qui brille de
la libre expression de la souveraineté
populaire quelle surprise la macronie
aurait-elle finalement consentie à
défendre la démocratie non monsieur
Ferrand petit serviteur du monarque
souhaite qu'Emmanuel Macron puisse
briguer un troisième mandat présidentiel
le valet du roi n'a pas digéré sa
défaite il défend la voix de son maître
pour mériter le prochain poste de
Premier ministre si certains en
doutaient encore la preuve est là notre
démocratie et les valeurs de la
République sont bafoués notre régime
sans force dans sa dérive autoritaire je
rappelle quand même que les deux
derniers présidents à avoir changé leur
constitution pour être réélu son Shinjin
pin et VL Poutine dirigeant
autoritaire
tenant leur pays d'une mannefer votre
gouvernement accumulé toutes les dérives
utilisation du 49.3 par 11 fois en moins
d'un an droit d'amendement remis en
cause arrestation politique utilisation
de la police pour réprimer les
manifestations surveillance vidéo
généralisée que vous faut-il de plus la
vision de la politique en macronie c'est
celle d'une élite déconnectée cumulant
les indemnités de mandat votre vision du
monde en fichier Excel vous aura poussé
à faire une réforme des retraites dont
plus de 70% de la population ne veut pas
monsieur le porte-parole du gouvernement
si vous souhaitez réellement la libre
expression de la souveraineté populaire
êtes-vous prêt à remettre en place le
RIC la reconnaissance du vote blanc et
la Sixième République
je vous remercie la parole est à
Monsieur Olivier Véran ministre
délégation du renouveau démocratique et
porte-parole du gouvernement merci
madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés madame la députée
Catherine couturier
j'ai entendu pardonnez-moi au début
couvert par les applaudissements j'ai
pas tout compris au début de la question
mais ayant entendu ayant entendu les
phrases cumulent dans le temps sans
limite voit de son maître et dérive
autoritaire j'imagine que vous lui
parlez du président Mélenchon
c'est pas de lui de vous parler de
Richard Ferrand ah bah écoutez je vous
parlez madame Richard ferrov écouter
m'interpeller du coup sur le propos de
Richard Ferrand dont l'absence ici
semble être vous être la plus cruelle
des présences comme l'exprimer en son
temps Marcel Proust madame la députée on
dit que lire cette interprété ça vient
pas de moi ça vient du romancier Henri
Miller et à entendre le nombre de
réactions depuis l'interview de Richard
Ferrand j'imagine qu'elle a été
extrêmement lue mais voyez-vous de
toutes les interprétations celles que
j'ai tendance à privilégier c'est celle
de son auteur à savoir Richard Ferrand
lui-même j'ajoute madame la députée et
vous serez d'accord avec moi que chacun
est libre de répondre aux questions de
la presse et d'en donner la juste
signification et par ailleurs je crois
qu'en politique il n'est pas interdit
d'être sincère en polémique et au
caricature madame la députée nous
préférons l'action et la raison mais
peut-être avant nous des mœurs se
politiques différentes on m'interroger
comme un ministre du renouveau
démocratique je vous réponds cette
fois-ci sur le fond je pense que des
l'évolution de la Constitution peuvent
être envisagées elles peuvent même être
souhaitables mais en l'occurrence pas
sur ce sujet et ce n'est pas d'ailleurs
ce qu'a dit Monsieur Richard Ferrand
madame la député nous sommes en 2023
nous ne sommes pas encore en 2026 notre
préoccupation c'est de répondre aux
besoins quotidiens des Français pas de
nous projeter dans une élection qui aura
lieu dans 4 ans et contrairement à vous
la préoccupation de ce gouvernement
n'est pas de savoir s'il faudrait
trancher la question du nombre de morts
présidentielles possibles mais de
répondre aux attentes du quotidien sur
l'emploi sur la sécurité la transition
énergétique le réarmement des services
publics afin qu'en 2027 madame la
députée les Français ne soient pas
tentés par un vote populiste ça doit
vous parler de votre populisme puisque
madame débute députés vous faites partie
de ceux qui l'incarnent je vous remercie
merci beaucoup monsieur le ministre
madame la députée
vous préférez combattre celles et ceux
qui agissent pour préserver notre
démocratie notre liberté de mouvement
plutôt que celles et ceux qui prônent le
racisme les xénophobie
je vous remercie la parraine est à
Monsieur Daniel Grenon pour le
rassemblement national
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues à monsieur le ministre de
l'Agriculture la peur du loup est une
peur ancestrale de l'homme l'homme a mis
des siècles à se débarrasser du loup en
France ce n'est que dans les années 30
que le loup a enfin disparu c'était
avant l'apparition des écologistes
depuis 1979 le loup bénéficie d'un
statut de protection absolue
statue que récemment la France n'a pas
voulu remettre en cause au nom de la
conservation de la vie sauvage le loup a
été réintroduit en France compris des
races qui n'ont historiquement jamais
peuplé la France souhaitons un retour
vers la vie sauvage or le danger ils se
sont multipliés dans 50 départements
français causant 4277 attaque en 2022 il
y a quelques semaines dans l'Yonne ils
se sont attaqués un taureau de plus
d'une tonne
malgré chiens et clôtures les mesures
prévues dans le cadre du Plan loup sont
nettement insuffisantes
certains préfets autorisent les tirs de
défense et là les décisions
préfectorales sont contestées par des
associations et le plus souvent invalidé
par les tribunaux même les tirs des
farouchements non les taux peuvent être
interdits au motifs qu'ils peuvent
perturber la gestation des Louvres en
préférant le lot aux moutons les
écologistes renvoient les moutons à un
élevage industriel en stabulation ils
vise à terme la disparition de
l'alimentation carnée au profit de la
viande artificielle de laboratoire nos
elfer nos éleveurs ne défendent pas
seulement l'organe peint ils aiment
leurs animaux et demandent juste la
conservation de leur mode de vie mais
vivent avec la crainte permanente d'une
attaque monsieur le ministre
attendez-vous qu'une personne humaine
soit attaquée par un loup pour que la
protection de la vie des éleveurs soient
réellement placés au-dessus de celle des
loups je vous remercie
et la
parole aussi
merci madame la Présidente Mesdames et
Messieurs les Députés monsieur le député
Grenon tout d'abord sachez que nous
mesurons pleinement l'as détresse des
éveils français face aux attaques des
loups nous sommes pleinement mobilisés
avec Marc féno pour trouver les
solutions les plus pertinentes et les
plus adaptées pour y faire face vous le
savez le loup est une espèce strictement
protégée revenue naturellement depuis
l'Italie en 1992 et notre priorité avec
Marc féno et bien d'assurer nos
engagements de protection tout en
permettant le pastoralisme d'exercer son
activité dans les meilleures conditions
possibles c'est en ce sens que nous
avons adopté en 2018 un plan d'action
avec la mise en place de mesures de
protection des troupeaux je pense
notamment aux aides au gardiennage par
les bergers à grande échelle aux achats
de clôture aux chiens également de
protection vous avez beaucoup évoqué
monsieur le député la politique de tir
dérogatoire à l'interdiction de
destruction en 2022 169 ont été prélevés
sur un plafond de 174 lots autorisés ce
qui correspond à la limite des 19% de la
population estimée et depuis le début de
l'année 58 loups ont été tués déjà je
dois rappeler que ce n'est pas le loup
que nous devons réguler mais bien les
attaques sur les troupeaux le
gouvernement a lancé l'élaboration du
futur plan national d'action pour la
période 2024-2029 qui est basé sur une
concertation parce que nous souhaitons
nous aussi des mesures toujours plus
efficaces nous allons échanger
évidemment avec les organisations
professionnelles agricoles également les
associations de protection de
l'environnement et je souhaite que ce
travail aboutisse à des solutions
équilibrées pour concilier les enjeux de
chacun sans les opposer comme vous le
faites notre priorité c'est de
simplifier la vie des éleveurs dont nous
connaissons les attentes je vous
remercie merci beaucoup monsieur le
député merci Madame présent dans les
années 30 c'était 40 millions
d'habitants qui peuplent le territoire
aujourd'hui c'est près de 70 millions
restaient-ils à 7 places pour les loups
la France ça n'a pas grandi depuis la
parole est à Madame Stéphanie cochère
pour le groupe horizon
merci madame la Présidente ma question
s'adresse à la ministre chargée de la
ruralité madame la ministre plus de 30%
n'ont concitoyens 22 millions de
Françaises et de français habitent en
territoire rural confronté à des
problématiques spécifiques en matière
d'accès aux soins au service public et
au commerce de proximité les habitants
de la ruralité parfois qualifiées de
France périphérique ont trop longtemps
été les oubliés de nos politiques
publiques créant un sentiment légitime
d'abandon et de déclassement
depuis 2017 une politique volontariste a
été menée en faveur de la ruralité par
le maintien des dotations de
fonctionnement après des années de
baisse par la revitalisation des
centres-villes et centre bourg avec les
programmes actions coeur de ville et
petite ville de demain ou bien encore
par le désenclavement avec
l'investissement dans les petites lignes
ferroviaires la 4G ou la fibre
cette promesse de la cohésion des
territoires pour que l'on bénéficie des
mêmes chances que l'on est et
grandissent en ville ou à la campagne
passe aussi par la création de maison
France services pour que le service
public réinvestissent les territoires
qu'ils soient plus proches et à visage
humain
je salue à ce titre le travail conduit
sur ce sujet pas ma collègue Marie-Agnès
Pousset vinsbach dans le cadre de sa
mission aux côtés du sénateur Bernard
delcro par toutes ces mesures qui font
l'agenda rural comme par le plan en
France ruralité que vous avez annoncé la
semaine dernière nous faisons de la
ruralité une priorité de notre action
cependant des inquiétudes demeurent sur
le terrain certes nous avons déployé un
fond de 90 millions d'euros sur trois
ans pour développer une offre de
mobilité durable innovantes et solidaire
dites du dernier kilomètre mais comment
s'assurer que nos plus petites communes
et leurs EPCI puissent se saisir de ce
fond pour déployer facilement des
solutions alternatives de mobilité je
vous remercie
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Dominique forme ministre délégué chargé
des collectivités territoriales et de la
ruralité
merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés madame
la députée cochère en fait vous appuyez
tous vos propos sur un sentiment de
relégation et d'abandon dans nos
ruralités c'est une réalité je la
partage et c'est pour ça que au terme de
cet agenda rural et de ses
investissements nous avons pris le sujet
à bras le corps effectivement les
ruralités sont au cœur de nos politiques
publiques vous citez trois points sur
lesquels je me permets de rebondir c'est
2750 maisons francs services qui font
aujourd'hui que moins de 30 minutes pour
tous les habitants de la ruralité
peuvent se rendre dans une maison France
service et c'est nous l'avons annoncé
madame la Première ministre l'a annoncé
la semaine dernière nous allons
renforcer l'accompagnement le soutien
que nous faisons auprès de nos mères
c'est 2500 euros de plus 5000 euros de
plus en fonction de ces zones de
revitalisation rurale en qui seront
déployés le second sujet que vous citez
c'est l'ingénierie je veux dire à quel
point cette ingénierie ces chefs de
projets vont s'appuyer sur les
ingénieries existantes à quel point
cette ingénierie sera partenariale les
Petr les départements les
intercommunalités ils portent de
l'ingénierie et on va travailler avec
nos chefs de projet à faire d'abord un
état des lieux pour venir accompagner
nos maires sur leurs projets de village
et pour finir vous nous dites mais
comment faire sur les mobilités je n'ai
un peu dit tout à l'heure la dernière
gare le dernier bus il reste 20 30 km et
c'est là que les 30 millions vont agir
comment tout simplement d'abord à la
maille intercommunale ce sont des
autorités organisatrices de la mobilité
en complément des régions qui vont agir
mais nous avons aussi beaucoup d'acteurs
je citer juste France ruralité qui porte
les mobilités solidaires et ce sont
toutes ces associations et ses aoméry
intercommunalité en fonction des
territoires qui vont véritablement
déployer des mobilités du dernier
kilomètre je vous remercie merci
beaucoup madame la ministre
la parole est à Monsieur Stéphane Viry
pour le couple républicain
merci merci beaucoup madame la
présidente madame la Première ministre
au 1er juillet prochain les tarifs de
vente de gaz réglementés vont prendre
fin pour les particuliers si la
disparition pardon de ce dispositif
était prévu dans la loi énergique climat
le contexte inflationniste que les
Français subissent depuis plus d'un an
impose me semble-t-il des mesures pour
protéger leur pouvoir d'achat et les
métiers hauts concrètement madame la
Première ministre la fin des tarifs
réglementés va imposer pour près de 3
millions de foyers français de changer
d'offre alors même que les prix de
l'énergie explosent en Europe du fait de
la reprise économique mondiale de notre
dépendance aux énergies fossiles ou de
la guerre en Ukraine la fade est tarifs
réglementés risque de pénaliser
davantage encore les Français qui
disposent d'une chaudière à gaz pour se
chauffer et qui vivent souvent en zone
rurale et qui n'ont a fortiori souvent
pas les moyens de s'équiper en pompe à
chaleur
par ailleurs nous savons que le prix du
gaz sera soumis à des mouvements
spéculatifs l'année prochaine ce qui va
invariablement engendrer une hausse
incontrôlable des prix madame la
Première ministre l'inflation sur les
produits alimentaires à atteint des
records en un an 18% pour le pain 36 %
pour les pâtes 62 % pour le sucre je
pourrais continuer l'électricité a
augmenté de plus de 15% pour les
particuliers les carburants eux aussi
ont augmenté et ont atteint des nouveaux
records pendant de nombreux mois et la
liste est longue les dépenses
contraintes des ménages sont de plus en
plus élevées c'est une réalité c'est le
quotidien de nombreux Français et
nombreux Français ne s'en sortent plus
alors même qu'ils travaillent et qu'il
gère leur budget madame la prairisme ma
question est simple comment comment
protéger ses français déjà lourdement
touchés par une inflation au corps et
menacée par la fin annoncée du bouclier
tarifaire
je vous remercie la parole est à Madame
Olivia Grégoire ministre délégué chargé
des PME du Commerce de l'Artisanat et du
Tourisme
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la Présidente Monsieur le
Député viril je vous prie d'excuser
l'absence de ma collègue ministre de
l'énergie
et je porte la réponse en son nom vous
l'avez dit conformément à la loi énergie
climat du 8 novembre 2019 les TRV tarifs
réglementé de vendre du gaz n'auront
n'existeront plus au 1er juillet 2023
pour les particuliers et les
copropriétés cette extinction concerne
près 2 millions de ménages sur les 10
millions qui sont chauffés au gaz les
autres c'est à dire plus de 80 % sont
d'ores et déjà sur des offres non
réglementées pour les ménages concernés
par le changement ils vont devoir eux
aussi basculer vers une offre non
réglementée je vous rappelle que cette
bascule vers des offres non réglementées
est déjà engagée depuis maintenant des
années quasiment 10 ans 2014 pour les
consommateurs professionnels comme les
PME et que ça s'est plutôt fait dans de
bonnes conditions concrètement c'est
assez simple ce sera sans impact sur les
factures les particuliers qui sont
aujourd'hui encore au TRV gaz peuvent
choisir d'ici fin juin l'offre tarifaire
de leur choix c'est-à-dire toujours chez
engie ou chers à un concurrent par
défaut la bascule sera automatique au
1er juillet sur l'offre dite
d'engie certains font du sujet TRV un
totem mais je crois qu'il faut garder le
sang froid la protection des
particuliers en période de pic de prix
c'est le bouclier tarifaire vous l'avez
mentionné monsieur le député Viry qui
concerne tous les consommateurs qu'ils
soient au TRV ou pas c'est important à
rappeler limiter la hausse à 15 % en
moyenne sur les factures d'énergie ça a
été quand même une stratégie plutôt
gagnante qui nous a quand même permis
d'avoir l'inflation la plus faible en
Europe cet hiver malgré la poussée
inflationniste que vous avez mentionné
Bruno le merle a annoncé hier aux
assises des finances publiques ce
bouclier n'est d'ailleurs plus
nécessaire pour le gaz au regard des
courses actuelles pour terminer nous
assurons que les consommateurs resteront
très informés c'est très important la
Commission de régulation à l'énergie la
creux va publier tous les mois un prix
de référence qui va refléter ce qui est
une offre correcte au regard des prix
sur les marchés européens je vous
remercie merci beaucoup madame la
ministre monsieur viré
je ne partage pas votre optimisme je
crains de la prédation de la part de
certaines offres et il y a une véritable
différence par rapport à ce mouvement
clencher depuis plusieurs années c'est
l'inflation qui n'existait pas jadis
désormais la donne est différente elle
les Français sont exposées
je vous remercie
la parole est à Madame Céline Calvez
pour le groupe Renaissance merci madame
la présidente Madame la Ministre des
Sports et des Jeux Olympiques est
paralympiques après de nombreux mois
d'incertitudes sur la diffusion en
France de la prochaine Coupe du Monde de
foot féminin enfin une solution a été
trouvée la semaine dernière et grâce à
votre impulsion car oui nous avons frôlé
un recul dans l'exposition médiatique du
sport féminin heureusement la diffusion
sera assurée pour notre pays par les
groupes M6 et France Télévisions
pourriez-vous nous donner les détails de
cet accord cet accord sur la coupe du
monde de foot version féminine nous
pouvons nous en réjouir mais force cette
constater que de nombreux efforts
restent à effectuer afin de renforcer la
visibilité du sport féminin au sein de
notre pays une récente étude de l'arcom
le révélait en 2021 moins de 5% des
retransmissions sportives étaient
consacrées au sport féminin
alors une meilleure diffusion médiatique
du sport féminin ça paraît essentiel
d'une part pour honorer les exploits de
nos sportifs françaises mais aussi pour
inspirer les femmes les jeunes filles
françaises à encore plus pratiqué le
sport et je sais que ce n'est pas
seulement par la plus grande visibilité
médiatique des sports que votre action
se déploie pour encourager cette
pratique si la chaîne ont parfois pu
redouter le manque d'engouement de des
téléspectateurs étaient les spectatrices
et bien on doit noter qu'il y a eu des
énormes succès d'audience que ça soit ce
sel pardon de la Coupe du monde de
football féminine en France en 2019 ou
encore plus récemment en avril dernier
pour le tournoi des 6 nations féminins
ça montre vraiment une compatibilité
entre l'audience et le sport féminin dès
lors comment le gouvernement agit pour
valoriser la diffusion du sport féminin
en France et qu'en est-il de
l'intégration des compétitions sportives
féminines au sein du décret e i m qui
protège la diffusion des événements
d'importance
y aura-t-il prochainement des mises à
jour de ce décret pour plus de
visibilité du sport féminin sur nos
télés je vous remercie merci beaucoup
la parole est à Madame Amélie ou da
Castéra ministre des Sports des Jeux
olympiques et paralympiques madame la
Présidente Mesdames et Messieurs les
Députés madame la députée Calvez on est
en effet soulagé et heureux de cet
accord on est soulagé parce que notre
équipe de France féminine talentueuse
uni plus motivée que jamais elle va
pouvoir être diffusée en effet cet été
pour cette compétition féminine de la
Coupe du Monde FIFA Australie
Nouvelle-Zélande elle se prépare elles
sont d'ailleurs ce matin dans leur
rassemblement autour d'Hervé Renard leur
coach emblématique à Clairefontaine on
est heureux on est soulagé parce qu'il y
a une très belle collaboration entre
deux groupes de l'audiovisuel privé et
public M6 France Télévisions qui se sont
bagarrées pour le sport féminin on est
heureux parce que la FIFA a su faire un
bon pas dans leur direction en
reconnaissant la qualité de l'offre
financière qui était proposée et la
qualité de l'exposition qu'elle était
celle de cette compétition sur les
chaînes du service public France 2 et
France 3 et sur W9 on est heureux aussi
avec ma collègue Rima Abdul Malak parce
que l'Europe une nouvelle fois a
démontré son utilité Rima avait mandaté
l'Union européenne des radiotés les
diffuseurs pour négocier à l'échelle
européenne pour qu'on ait plus de
leviers et moi même j'avais mobilisé mes
homologues européens britannique
italiens espagnols allemands pour qu'on
aligne au mieux toutes les énergies
alors on va continuer ce deal il est
intelligent il se fait en synergie avec
un autre accord sur la diffusion des
matchs de l'équipe de France par France
Télévisions et M6 avec la Fédération
Française de foot et en complémentarité
avec un autre accord celui du groupe
Canal+ pour le championnat donc nous
avec le décret EIM on va continuer pas
seulement pour le foot féminin pour le
rugby pour le volley pour le basket
aussi pour des grandes compétitions
comme le Tour de France féminin pour le
handball et je voudrais terminer par ce
fait que hier soir on avait ce match
France Grèce notre équipe de France
masculine à l'échauffement portait le
maillot de l'équipe de France féminine
et quand je vois ça je me dis que pour
le sport féminin dans le foot en France
aujourd'hui on est vraiment en train de
changer d'époque merci merci beaucoup
madame la ministre
la parole est un monsieur Frédéric
maillot pour le groupe GDR la présidente
madame la Première ministre aujourd'hui
cela fait un an que nous sommes élus un
an que nous portons la voie de nos
concitoyens ultramarins et plus
particulièrement celle des Outre-mer
celle des Réunionnais en ce qui me
concerne c'est un an de lutte un an
d'alerte sur la précarité qui touche les
peuples d'outre-merde un an de mandat
c'est un an de combat c'est 365 jours
d'alerte non-stop sur dans cette
situation devenue intolérable cela fait
un an que nous députés dit d'outre-mer
nous alertons sur le coup de la vie dans
nos territoires tout est cher manger se
déplacer communiquer et même s'amuser
tout cela dans une situation de duo-paul
monopole économique avec la complicité
de l'État qui profite aux grandes
industries cela même qui tenait le fouet
pendant l'esclavage cela fait un an que
nous interpellons sur le coup exorbitant
des billets d'avion avec des
augmentations qui vont jusqu'à 40% un an
que nous alertons sur la dégradation
accélérée des services publics dans nos
territoires manque de conciliateur de
justice manque d'adsh saturation des
hôpitaux insalubrités de certaines
prisons cela fait un an que nous crions
nous le désespoir de nos frères de nos
soeurs qui veulent rentrer travailler au
pays en Guadeloupe Martinique Guyane et
à la Réunion un an c'est 365 jours à
attiré votre attention ici en hémicycle
en commission ou encore dans nos pays
mais que feriez-vous si cette situation
était la même en France hexagonale les
outre-mer sont toujours les grands
oubliés de vos projets de loi nous
sommes toujours à la périphérie de vos
décisions Madame et Monsieur les
ministres de vagues promesses de décret
ne font pas une politique des
spécificités d'outre-merdes absentes de
vos lois à votre bilan il est là de
l'oubli non que dis-je de l'indifférence
à l'état pur mesdames et messieurs du
gouvernement s'il fallait vous donner
une note ça serait zéro sur 365 ma
question est simple quand allez-vous
réellement considérez les 2,2 millions
de hommes et de femmes en
ultramarins que nous sommes enfants des
colonies notre jour de gloire n'est pas
près d'arriver
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
madame la Présidente Monsieur le Député
maillot évidemment nous nous voyons
souvent je connais votre discours et
vous connaissez
et vous connaissez ma réponse c'est que
jamais depuis longtemps aucun
gouvernement n'agit autant
c'est comme ça dès la loi pouvoir
d'achat et l'aller faire 2022 des
dispositions spécifiques ont été
adoptées plafonnement des loyers aide
alimentaire revalorisation de la partse
le pellet 2023 a fait la part belle à
l'émission outre-mer pour la première
fois le budget frôle les 3 milliards
d'euros et le total des dépenses
outre-mer de l'ensemble des ministères
atteint 22 milliards le rapport entre la
population et le budget est clair les
outre-mer sont au cœur des soucis de ce
gouvernement des mesures spécifiques ont
également été adoptées pour les
franchises de colis la prolongation de
la défiscalisation jusqu'en 2021 la loi
relative à l'accélération de la
production d'énergie renouvelable
prévoit des adaptations ultramarines la
loi de programmation militaire cruciale
pour la protection de nos concitoyens
donne une place centrale au territoire
ultrama je voudrais rappeler dire devant
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale que c'est en outre-mer qui a
le plus beau taux de création d'emplois
que c'est en outre-mer que le taux
d'inflation est le plus faible que c'est
nous travaillons le plus pour que nous
travaillons le plus pour aider les plus
démunis nous pouvons encore aller plus
loin et c'est le sens du prochain comité
interministériel de l'outre-mer que
madame la Première ministre présidera le
6 juillet et vous connaissez le contenu
que je proposerai madame la Première
ministre donc vous ne pouvez pas dire
cela comme ça l'ensemble des efforts
sont faits c'est éminemment difficile en
août tout n'est pas législatif des
Outre-mer ont aussi besoin de respirer
c'est l'essence des dynamiques de
dialogues et de co-construction que nous
menons depuis un an pour alléger les
contraintes libérer le potentiel de
création de tous les territoires le
gouvernement continuera agir avec tous
les moyens à sa disposition pour
améliorer le quotidien de nos
concitoyens c'est pas facile mais vous
le savez mais vous le savez aussi que
nous y travaillons avec les présidents
de collectivités avec tous les parleurs
ultramarins et notamment avec vous
est un monsieur Sébastien Petavy pour le
coupé écologiste
[Applaudissements]
merci madame la présidente monsieur le
ministre mes chers collègues je voudrais
vous alerter sur le calvaire que vit
depuis 7 ans Nabila essaoui atteinte
demielegies Nabila vit ou du moins
survie dans un logement social qui n'est
pas accessible aux personnes en
situation de handicap contrairement à ce
qu'affirme son bailleur le groupe 3F
elle est contrainte de rampe pour
accéder à sa douche et de s'élancer
depuis son fauteuil pour rejoindre son
lit ce qui a déjà provoqué plusieurs
chutes et blessures désespéré face au
silence des pouvoirs publics et au refus
répétés de son bailleur de la reloger
dans un logement accessible Nabilla a
commencé jeudi dernier une grève de la
fin alors monsieur le ministre je
m'interroge non pas sans colère de
quelle dignité parlons-nous lorsqu'une
locataire est forcée de ramper pour
prendre une douche cette situation que
vinabella est inacceptable mais n'est
pas isolée l'état failli avec Nabila
comme il faillit chaque jour avec les 12
millions de personnes en situation de
handicap dans notre pays il faillit
lorsqu'il adopte une loi élan régressive
qui réduit la part de logements neufs
accessible de 100 à 20%
et il faillit lorsque des enfants en
situation de handicap se retrouvent sans
école faute d'Osh le Conseil
constitutionnel la sanctuarisé le droit
à un logement décent et donc un logement
accessible alors que le handicap est le
premier objet de discrimination je
voudrais vous rappeler monsieur le
ministre que l'accessibilité n'est ni
une faveur ni une option c'est un droit
fondamental et une condition d'égalité
entre toutes et tous Cela fait
maintenant six jours que Nabilla se
prive de nourriture dans l'espoir qu'on
l'écoute enfin alors ma question est la
suivante comment peut-on en arriver à
une telle humiliation pourquoi n'y
a-t-il aucun contrôle sur les logements
que comptez-vous faire pour donner une
réponse rapide à Nabila et à toutes les
personnes en situation de handicap à qui
l'on refuse encore aujourd'hui un
logement accessible
je vous remercie mon cher collègue la
parole est à Monsieur Olivier Klein
ministre délégué chargé de la ville et
du Logement merci madame la Présidente
Mesdames et Messieurs les Députés
monsieur le député Sébastien Petavy
permettez-moi si vous êtes d'accord de
ne pas vous répondre sur le cas
particulier de la dame dont vous faites
état dont nous connaissons la situation
dans notre suivons cette situation
évidemment de manière extrêmement
attentive avec le bailleur 3F qui est
son bailleur et je vous tiens à votre
disposition l'ensemble des éléments est
bien évidemment nous cherchons avec les
pouvoirs publics et le bailleur une
nouvelle solution pour cette personne
car il y a déjà eu des évolutions dans
son parcours résidentiel néanmoins je
vais élargir ma réponse vous le savez
lors du de la Conférence nationale du
handicap qui a déjà été évoqué lors de
cette séance de question gouvernement
qui s'est tenue en avril dernier le
président de la République a rappelé
notre ambition de faire de
l'accessibilité une priorité nationale
nos concitoyons nos concitoyens en
situation de handicap doivent pouvoir
accéder au même endroit et participer
pleinement à la vie publique et le
logement fait partie bien évidemment de
cet objectif cet objectif
d'accessibilité universelle partout et
pour tous c'est souvent le point de
départ de nombreuses difficultés ou de
nombreuses réussites notamment le lien
entre l'emploi et le logement le lien
entre le les études et le logement sont
au cœur de nos de nos préoccupations
lors du CNH nous avons fait plusieurs
annonces notamment celle que le
dispositif m'a pris madame sera ouvert à
l'ensemble des personnes en situation du
handicap sans condition d'âge bien
évidemment et cet accompagnement
financier dans l'adaptation du logement
qu'il soit privé ou social sera une
priorité extrêmement importante nous
allons ensuite pour répondre à une
partie de votre question mieux
identifier les logements accessibles
dans le parc privé mais aussi dans le
parc social pour que il n'y ait pas de
entre guillemets de très très mauvaise
surprise lors de l'attribution d'un
logement et c'est l'objectif de cette
cartographie que nous allons mettre en
œuvre enfin et vous l'avez là aussi
rappelé la loi 3DS a ouvert le DALO aux
personnes vivant dans un logement
inadapté à leur situation et à leur
situation du handicap ou lorsque dans
cette famille il y a une personne en
situation de handicap donc voilà nous
sommes extrêmement mobilisés et pour la
question particulière on peut en parler
dans quelques secondes merci merci
beaucoup monsieur le ministre la séance
des questions au Gouvernement est
terminée la séance est